[Musique]
François langanglais bonsoir bonsoir
nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle servview nous
sommes en direct est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter sucintement et bien je
suis journaliste journaliste économiquef
dans ces deux mots c'est le premier qui
plus important je crois parce que c'est
ça qui détermine la façon dont
j'envisage l'économie je ne suis pas un
économiste mais je m'attache à faire le
lien entre les différents domaines la
société la politique la géopolitique en
ce moment c'est clé et l'économie je
fais ce métier de journaliste depuis une
quarantaine d'années j'ai commencé dans
ce qu'on appelait au début des années 80
les nouvelles technologies qui
aujourd'hui semblent évidemment
pasétuvienne le Minitel et puis je suis
parti ensuite en Chine où j'ai enseigné
la littér littérature française pendant
un moment c'était mon service militaire
et à partir de là j'ai commencé à faire
des piches pour différents journaux dont
L'Express qui m'a envoyé couvrir aussi
le la fin du régime militaire en Corée
du Sud quand chunowan est tombé à la en
1987 j'ai développé une compétence sur
l'Asie au fil de mes voyages pendant ces
quelques années et je suis rentré en
France je me suis fait embaucher par un
journal économique pour faire de
l'étranger Scien vie économie puis
l'expansion ensuite où là j'ai appris
vraiment l'économie avec mes maîtres des
journalistes expérimenté c'était Gérard
mati Henri gibier notamment qui était
les rédacteurs en chef de ce beau
journal c'était une époque révolu hein
où la presse vivait bien on avait des
moyens pour faire des voyages des
enquêtes et puis je suis resté une
dizaine d'années dans l'expansion j'ai
grimpé les échelons je suis devenu
directeur adjoint j'ai dirigé après deux
autres journaux économiques pour
finalement atterrir à la télévision un
peu par hasard je ne pensais pas du tout
être fait pour la télévision et puis
puis finalement je me'y suis fait
accoutumé d'abord en faisant des
interviews de personnes politiques he de
de responsable politique à France 2 unee
émission dirigée par David Pujadas qui
s'appelait Des paroles et des actes et
puis après en intégrant la rédaction
plus tard parallèlement j'ai pris une
chronique à la radio quotidienne à RTL
où je suis depuis 10 ans et depuis j'ai
rejoint TF1 et LCI où je suis
chroniqueur économique parallèlement
j'ai une vie de d'auteur de livres j'ai
écrit une dizaine de livres depuis 15
ans le premier date de 2007 il
s'appelait la crise des années 30 est
devant nous c'était un livre qui
expliquer comment et pourquoi on allait
connaître une crise financière on
envoyait les signes
précurseurs manifestes me semblaitt-il à
l'époque et et depuis c'est toujours un
peu le même thème au fil de ces livres
c'est le même mais sous des angles
différents la thèse étant que on vit une
crise de transition où tous dérègl un
peu en même temps la géopolitique
l'économie la société
et que c'est pas la première fois que ça
arrive ça arrive d'ailleurs de façon
assez curieuse relativement
régulièrement dans l'histoire mondiale
tous les 80 ou 90 ans et que on est
probablement à la fin de cette période
de transition la période la plus
désagréable et donc je je m'attache à
décrire ce passage là au disons à la à
la lecture à la lumière évidemment du
passé parce que je considère que dans
l'étude des sociétés
humaines et l'économie est évidemment un
sous-ensemble de l'étude des sociétés
humaines ce qui ne change pas est plus
important que ce qui
change bienvenue sur notre chaîne on a
décidé de faire on a décidé de vous
faire venir parce que on vous trouve
pour la plupart du temps en général très
pédagogueoné à annoncer les mauvaises
nouvelles avec une voix de
CER la voix c'est 30 ans de de tabac
blond je pense que radio hein c'est
peut-être oui je sais pas si l'organe
qui a fait la fonction ou la fonction
qui a fait l'organe j'en sais rien et
donc euh on va parler de choses
compliquées ce soir de géopolitique de
fonds monétairees de banque centrale de
politique monétaire de soutenabilité des
dettes de soutenabilité de la monnaie de
l'élargissement de l'Europe du monde il
y a tellement de choses à discuter on n
pas pu avoir Bruno lomer ce soir donc on
a décidé d'avoir quelqu'un de plus
performant et en terme de connaissance
donc François l'anglais comment vous
percevez la politique des banques
centrales d'augmentation des taux
quelles vont être les répercussions sur
le marché de l'emploi sur l'inflation
sur la stacflation est-ce que c'est un
choc volkeer en mode light ou comme à la
papa en utilisant les vieux mécanismes
parce qu'on est tellement embourbé de on
va droit dans le mur enchantant et en
faisant des gros chèqus de dette comment
vous percevez les politiques économies
des banques centrales et ensuite on
descendra d'un échelon comment c'est
retransmis à nos ministres de
l'économie je crois que pour le
comprendre cette politique actuelle des
banques centrales il faut revenir en
arrière et notamment dans les quelques
dernières années qu'on a vécu avec des
taux d'intérêt extrêmement
faiblees pendant plusieurs années on
était autour de zéro voire même en
dessous de zéro et ça a eu des effets de
dérèglement considérables sur tout
l'économie notamment le dérèglement le
plus important c'est l'extraordinaire
croissance de l'endettement on se
focalise bien sûr sur l'endettement
public ça n'en est qu'une des
manifestation il y a l'endettement privé
des ménages l'endettement des des
entreprises quel que soit l'indicateur
que vous prenez quel que soit le pays
que vous considérez on est au record ou
quasiment de de l'histoire en temps de
paix temps de guerre c'est autre chose
parce que
évidemment pendant la dernière dernière
guerre mondiale on a on a on a dépensé
considérablement mais pour des raisons
évidemment toutes autres en temps de
paix si on consolide l'ensemble des des
des des dettes mondiales on arrive à un
chiffre qui est inédit alors les experts
se battent là-dessus on peut considérer
que l'ordre de grandeur c'estes 3 années
de PIB mondial à peu près et encore on
ne sait pas tout parce que en sachant
que le PIB mondial c'est oh écoutez je
j'ai plus le en tête l'ordre de grandeur
on doit être aux alentours de 70000
milliards de dollars quelque chose comme
ça hein je vous dis ça de mémoire donc
mais ça sera certainement corrigé
précisément par l'un de vos auditeurs
attentifs et exert plateforme de fact
checking Capitel
fact mais et on ne sait pas tout parce
que il y a beaucoup de dettes dans ce
qu'on appelle la finance de l'ombre
c'est-à-dire qui passe en dessous du
radar et et alors il il y a des il y a
des évidemment des des systèmes de
connexion entre la
finance éclairée et la finance de
l'ombre mais mais qu'est-ce que vous
appelez finance de l'ombre parce que
tout de suite ça fait un peu suspect
finance de long non c'est pas c'est par
exemple alors c'est quoi c'est du window
dracing pour améliorer le le bilan des
des boîtes en fin d'année c'est des
transactions qui ne sont pas réglementés
par les autorités de marché c'est les
Dark pool c'est quoi il y a bien sûr cet
aspect là dark pool c'est pas à ça que
je pensais c'était par exemple à ce qui
se passe en Chine je crois que c'est le
plus préoccupant où vous avez tout un
tas de véhicules publics ou parab public
qui ont été chargés de dettes
considérabl et et qui n'apparaissent pas
dans les chiffres officiels hein parce
que euh les Chinois en fait la la
croissance l'extraordinaire croissance
de la Chine c'est accompagné d'une
débauche d'endettement à une époque où
la Chine avait son PIB qui progressait
de 10 ou 12 % par an et avait une
inflation de 10 ou 12 % par an vous avez
le PIB nominal qui augmente de 25 points
par année ça veut dire que la dette
accumulé diminue en gros de 25 % chaque
année ça vous permet de continuer à vous
endetter sans limite quasiment
aujourd'hui c'est plus du tout le cas la
croissance chinoise on sait pas
exactement à combien elle est vous savez
c'est assez curieux mais la Chine est le
le pays qui publie ses statistiques de
PIB le plus rapidement alors que
c'est pas la plus grande économie du
monde mais la seconde donc ça pose
question quand même sur la la qualité
des chiffres comment vous faites pour
croiser les données officielles de du
gouvernement chinois avec la réalité il
y a un indicateur qui est intéressant la
consommation énergétique ouais c'est le
meilleur c'est le meilleur euh parce que
vous voyez bon évidemment c'est moins
moins fiable maintenant qu'il y a 10 ans
parce que l'économie chinoise est en
train non pas de se désindustrialiser
mais le poids relatif de l'industrie est
plus faible qu'il y a 10 ans les
services se développent les services
sont moins consommateurs d'industrie
même si le le le l'Internet consomme
consomme de l'électricité donc c'est
peut-être un petit peu moins précis que
ça ne pouvait être mais quand même hein
et puis bon vous avez quand même les les
mouvements de population qui sont
décrits ces travailleurs migrants qui
passent d'une région à l'autre donc ça
aussi les observateurs là-bas font des
rapports il il les raconte notamment
dans la presse anglo-saxonne dans le
Financial Times c'est c'est pour partie
des correspondants pour partie des
experts qui racontent ce qu'il voi donc
ce ne sont que des données parcellaires
mais ce sont des indicateurs importants
la croissance est faible en Chine
l'inflation est à zéro ça veut dire que
il n'y a plus moyen de faire diminuer la
dette avec l'ardoise magique c'est plus
possible donc du coup ce sont les
provinces qui s'en dettent et elles
l'ont fait pendant des années en mettant
comme collatérale la valeur des terrains
vous savez que la Chine a connu un bom
imobilier extraordinaire et que à un
moment on a cru que c'était une monnaie
éternelle dont la dont la valeur allait
progresser sans cesse c'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui il y a il y a des villes
entières qui ont été construites et qui
ne trouvent pas preneur g mais ça fait
15 ans que ça existe oui enfin là si
vous
voulez ces chosesl on on dit bah ça peut
durer tout le temps en réalité à un
moment donné on est rattrapé par la
réalité parce
que malgré tout la réalité se venge he
c'est le propre des économies de bulle
si vous voulez et vous savez c'est ket
rogof qui est un économiste américain et
qui qui dit finalement dès qu'on entend
cette fois-ci ça n'est pas la même chose
il faut vendre parce que ça veut dire
que justement c'est toujours la même
chose et que l'éclatement de la bulle se
prépare et et on a pu dire la même chose
sur la Chine on a pu dire attention en
Chine c'est pas pareil parce que c'est
une économie énorme qui a un potentiel
considérable non non non non les
déterminants fondamentaux restent les
mêmes quand on s'endettete comme une
brute et que parallèlement il y a une
pression démographique très puissante un
seul chiffre là-dessus qui est quand
même incroyable chaque année la
population active chinoise diminue de 7
millions de Gus alors il y a du stock
évidemment il en reste 900 millions mais
mais le mouvement va s'accentuer donc
vous avez la la conjonction d'une dette
importante accumulée pendant les années
fol d'une rétraction de la population
active de d'un contexte géopolitique qui
fait que les exportations chinoises sont
quand même de plus en plus menacé tout
ça dessine un futur pour la Chine qui
est assez qui n'est pas du tout le même
quoi j'en reviens à la dette quand je
disais finance cachées je pensais à ça à
C à ces à ces ces dettes qui
n'apparaissent pas dans les statistiques
officiel mais qui réapparaîtront un jour
dans les bilans quelque part
immanquablement l'État va être obligé de
de de de récupérer tout ça donc euh j'en
reviens à votre question qui était qui
portait sur les le choc volc
d'aujourd'hui il n'est compris ch volka
c'est quoi bah un choc volkerer c'est
c'est une montée brutale des taux
d'intérêt comme l'avait fait Paul Volker
à la fin des années 90 et et à un moment
où on a voulu se débarrasser de
l'inflation et Volker qui était le
patron de la banque fédérale qui était
américaine pardon américaine
pardonnez-moi la banque centrale
américaine et
euh donc a décidé avec un ensemble de de
responsables économiques à cette
époque-là de faire baisser l'inflation
et il a fait monter les taux
considérablement c'est ça qui a provoqué
la récession du début des années 80
récession quasi mondiale he elle a eu
ses impacts en Europe un petit peu plus
tard en 80 82 mais donc on compare la
période actuelle à volkaire parce que la
montée des taux d' intérêt a été très
rapide encore plus rapide que sousvkaire
d'ailleurs hein l'ampleur était moindre
et de de sur cro le le l'inflation était
plus faible hein avant notre inflation
que celle que celle de volka je on y
reviendra si vous le souhaitez sur
l'inflation ou sur la dé
publicilation je ne pense pas que en
fait l'inflation est disparue vraiment à
cause de volkaire hein mais on y
reviendra c'est une question très
importante qui nous concerne aujourd'hui
mais euh ces banques centrales elles se
sont laissées euh prendre un peu en
otage à la fois par les acteurs de
l'économie financière et les
gouvernements qui ont tous deux intérêt
à s'endetter et c'est je te tiens et tu
me tiens par la barbichette donc on a
connu la période du covid un certain
nombre de chocs économiques pendant
lesquels la banque centrale a voulu
maintenir le bazar quoi qu'il arrive
quoi qu'il en coûte hein donc on a
baissé les taux d'intérêt pour
stabiliser l'économie avec l'idée que
finalement pouvait ainsi financer des
dettes quasiment perpétuelles puisqueun
jour ou l'autre la banque centrale les
récupérerait elle les détruirait et on
s'en sortirait comme avant c'est
évidemment ce sont des bvesés ce sont
des bvesés et et et on y reviendra aussi
parce que c'est une réflexion qui peut
nous mener très loin quant à la valeur
de la monnaie c'est ça qui est en jeu
aujourd'huiiance plutôt oui c'est pareil
c'est pareil enfin à mon sens c'est la
même chose c'est-à-dire que le le le ce
qui fait la valeur au bout du du bout du
bout c'est la confiance hein c'est un
bout de papier c'est un bout de papier
la monnaie ou ou des zéros sur un
ordinateur donc ça ne vaut rien on a
décorrelllé la la monnaie du métal
précieux l'or en EN 71 c'est c'est c'est
c'est
Nixon et et et ça a été le début de la
montée en scène des banques centrales
pour créer de la monnaie indépendamment
de la création de richesse ça s'est
déconnecté petit à petit le SOMUM étant
atteint au moment du covid où on a
complètement déjanté et on a financé à
partir de rien tout un tas de transferts
qui étaient peut-être nécessairire pour
des raisons politique peu importe mais
le reste que on a créé de la monnaie qui
n'avait pas de racine réelle quant à la
création de richesse réelle c'est-à-dire
des biens fabriqués des services rendus
des technologies inventées des salaires
versés tout ça n'a pas existé
basiquement de l'énergie de la
nourriture évidemment évidemment
évidemment t ce sont même les
déterminants fondamentaux de la
croissance l'énergie et la nourriture et
et et donc on on a il y a même des des
des bouquins qui ont été écrits à
l'époque je pense à celui de Stephanie
Kelton aux États-Unis qui a eu beaucoup
d'écho dans le monde entier qui
légitimaient tout cela en disant mais de
quoi vous plaignez on a trouvé la pierre
philosophale finalement on peut
fabriquer de la monnaie quasiment autant
que nous le souhaitons et ça n'est pas
grave parce que les États sont
solevables à perpétuité et ils sont
garantis par les banques centrales qui
elles-mêmes sont solides comme le rock
bilvzé bilvusé et et ce qui s'est l'une
des conséquences c'est pas la seule mais
l'une des conséquences de de cette
période de taux zéro ça a été
l'inflation d'aujourd'hui je pense que
d'un certain côté l'économie s'est
vengée et a nous a repris sous la forme
de la dévalorisation de la monnaie ce
qui nous avait été donné pendant la
période de création monétaire où euh ça
c'était déconnecté de la création de
richesse peut-être même avant avec le
Quantitative eing sous bien sûr bien sûr
2008 ben Bernand mais tout à fait en
fait on utilise la même technique avec
une ampleur croissante et ça a commencé
en 71 avec Nixon quand il veut financer
la guerre du du Vietnam qui n'a pas
assez d'argent donc il déconnecte à
l'époque si ma mémoire est bonne le le
l'on d'or vaut 35 dollars et il dit
c'est fini maintenant l'on d'or bah on
elle sera côté sur le marché et nous
pour nous endettter ils profitent du du
statut d'émetteur de monnaie mondiale
qu' qu'à les États-Unis et qu' les
États-Unis pardon et qui l'ont en partie
encore aujourd'hui on y reviendra si
vous le souhaitez et depuis c'est vrai
que il y a eu 87 craque boursiers là
encore les banques centrales sont tenus
en otage par les marchés financiers qui
leur disent ils leur disent pas
enfin au fond les banques centrales le
savent attention si tu si tu nous
laisses tomber c'est la dépression et le
coût pour la société sera considérable
greenPan baisse c t massivement et et
entre dans cette boucle là qu'on
retrouve en 98 avec la crise des marchés
émergents notamment la crise russe et
son enfin la crise thaïlandaise qui
débute le 2 juillet 97 si m moire est
bonne tous les pays émergents tombent on
baisse les taux d'intérêt pour la même
raison on le fait évidemment massivement
en 2008 200009 à d'ailleurs il y a une
espèce de contetemps parce qu'au début
les banques centrales notamment la
Banque centrale européenne ne comprend
pas ce qui se passe hein à l'été 2008
elle remonte ces eau en disant la
croissance est là tout va bien et cetera
immédiatement après octobre elle elle
elle se met à l'unisson de de de la
Fédérale réserve américaine et de la
quasi totalité des banques centrales
mondiales pour baisser les taux et et et
on a connu le paroxisme de cette affaire
làà avec le covid donc il faut avoir ça
en tête quand on parle de la montée des
tau aujourd'hui elles ont elles ont
probablement attendu trop longtemps en
en R de taux zéro avec l'idée les bvesés
de Stéphanie Kelton et des autres que
finalement tout ça n'avait aucune
conséquence et que il n'y aurait pas de
facture finale et et du coup elle
surcompense aujourd'hui en montant comme
des brutes et elles le font avec l'idée
simple qui est l'idée de la politique
monétaire qui est que à partir du moment
où vous montez les taux d'intérêt vous
renchérissez le coût du crédit donc vous
diminuez la demande économique donc les
producteurs ne peuvent plus augmenter
leur prix faute de quoi ils ne vendent
plus leurs biens c'est-à-dire si on dit
les choses d'une autre façon on tue la
demande exactement on programme une
récession en fait on ne sait pas très
bien lutter contre l'inflation sans
provoquer une récession donc c'est ce
qu' ce qu'on fait les banques centrales
elles ont chargé leur fusil he en 2022
et elles tirent toutes les balles on
voit là elles comprennent que la bête et
pas mourante mais enfin en tout cas bien
blessée donc il semble que elle fasse
une pause hein et je je ne sais pas
quelle sera la suite de l'histoire mais
il y a il y a bien ce qu'on appelle un
tradeof en anglais c'est un mot assez
moche mais au fond une espèce d'échange
entre une récession contre la la baisse
de l'inflation et c'est ce pareil là que
tentent les banques centrales
aujourd'hui alors il fallait de toute
façon sortir de la politique de taux
zéro c'était indispensable parce que
outre le dérèglement inflationniste dont
on vient de parler il y en a un autre
qui est presque encore plus
problématique c'est l'extraordinaire
gonflement du marché des actifs
financiers
hein et et et là
c'est disons il il y a d'un certain côté
un désastre qui nous attend il y aura
une correction il y aura une correction
il y a une différence entre une
correction et per permettez-moi le mot
un peu vulgaire se prendre une grosse
branlée
oui je justement j'allais y
venir tout dépend comment ça se
passe un choc brutal sur la valeur des
des actions des actifs est-ce qu'on peut
mettre un peu plus le contexte donc
imaginez-vous on se prend un choc brutal
sur ces actifs ouais à l'heure actuelle
notre économie elle est un petit peu
comment dire flagada flagada
ouais non su flagada c'est ou un peu un
peu pas bien genre un peu sorti de
soirée compliquée un petit peu mal à la
tête on traîne un covid avec limite on
se demande si c'est pas un petit cancer
qu'on est en train de déployer compliqué
si on applique un choc comme ça sur déjà
une une une économie une société qui est
profondément malade avec aucune
proposition politique derrière aucune
communication politique ça donne quoi
quand on connecte tous les petits points
de on va se prendre une grosse vague
dans la tête mais déjà on est en short
sans palme sans masque sans tubaas et on
est déjà essoufflé parce que on a été
obligé de rattraper Marie mamie qui
était en train de se noyer dans les
vagues un choc les pensions de retraite
on en parlera aussi oui un choc comme ça
ça sera dévastateur alors est-ce que
c'est les politiques qui sont
pertinemment au courant que on va se
prendre un choc dans la tête savent
pertinemment que notre société est déjà
un petit peu flagada et se disent
bon vaut mieux s'endetter encore un
petit peu un petit peu le temps qu'on
peut on achète du temps il est très très
cher mais on se garantit peut-être un
peu plus de calme pour réfléchir
j'essaie de me faire l'avocat du diable
du politique ou c'est du déni c'est de
la subornation de vote avec de de de la
dette publique et en veux-tu en voilà on
y va et puis de toutes les façons moi je
prends ma retraite dans 3 ans je pars
avec le portefeuille et le carnet
d'adresse de la République et je vais me
reconvertir dans le privé à faire des
conférences à 100000 balles par mois je
pense ball la conférence il y a un peu
il y a il y a un peu tout ça
euh il y a aussi c'est un manque de
courage non mais je pense que si vous
voulez il y a aussi je pense le le le
fait que on est accoutumé à ce mondelà
depuis déjà tellement longtemps qu'au
fond je ne suis pas sûr que tout le
monde comprenne
l'enjeu ça vient de quoi de l'éducation
à l'école les journalistes font pas leur
boulot pour vulgariser l'information ils
se mettent trop sous le robinet de
l'information des banques centrales du
gouvernement où ça vient ù ça vient
simplement du fait que la majeur partie
sont
designards non je je pense que c'est
c'est que ça dure depuis plusieurs
décennies et qu'on a fini par considérer
ça comme le monde normal et que du coup
on entre dans une espèce d'illusion
collective qui est le propre des
périodes qui précèdent les crises parce
que si vous voulez il y a un moment où
justement la réalité frappe au carreot
tellement fort que tout le monde dit ah
mais on aurait dû se rendre compte et en
réalité quand on élargit la la focale on
voit ça justement et qu'on on on compare
avec les périodes précédentes mais si
vous
voulez je pense que les banques
centrales savent évidemment très
précisément ça pour le coup il a il y a
pas de doute là-dessus enfin je n'en ai
pas peut-être que je me trompe mais à
mon avis le scénario le plus probable
c'est pour ça que je crois que cette
montée des taux n'ira pas très très haut
parce que il y a un plafond en fait les
banques centrales naviguent entre deux
dangers c'est Carib descila d'un côté
vous avez l'inflation de l'autre côté
vous avez crise financière donc le
taquet absolu à pas taper c'est la crise
financière mais je vous fiche mon billet
c'est le cas de le dire que cher que
dans je ne sais pas 3 mois 6 mois 9 mois
12 mois les taux recommenceront à
descendre parce que l'économie va
ralentir et que on va se rendre compte
qu'il y a de vrais risques sur la
stabilité financière donc on on on reste
dans cette espèce de de disons
d'alternative entre C
euh taux élevé pour assaignir le le le
marché de la dette et crise financière
quoi hein et je ne vois pas très bien
comment en sortir sauf à euh provoquer
une correction justement ou une une une
chute des actif qui me semble-t-il se
produira immanquablement je suis
incapable de l'Ader peut-être que on a
toujours le sentiment que euh dans dans
ce dans ces situations-l que les choses
sont imminentes euh en réalité c'est
toujours plus long qu'on ne le croit
parce qu'il y a des résistances parce
qu'il y a des intérêts il y a des
intérêts qui sont très puissants et qui
empêchent les les les corrections et et
à l'inverse on il y a une illusion
symétrique au moment où la crise se se
déclenche c'est que ça va toujours
beaucoup plus vite qu'on croit une fois
que la crise est déclenchée donc elle
est toujours beaucoup plus lente à se
déclencher qu'on le pense mais une fois
que c'est déclenché elle est beaucoup
plus rapide à se développer parce que à
ce moment-là ce sont des mécanismes
psychologiques classiques c'est les
moutons de Panurge que nous sommes tous
hein c'est la la psych finalement si
vous voulez depuis Gustave Lebon on na
rien appris mais exactement c'est le
meilleur livre pour comprendre la
finance la psychologie des foules c'est
le meilleur livre pour pour comprendre
la finance enfin j'exagère mais mais
souvenez-vous de Myon SCHS prix Nobel
2001 qui invente des formules
invraisemblables et qui couronné pour ça
qui provoque euh la la faillite de de de
de de de fond je crois que c'est LTCM à
l'époque bon
euh le le le type en gros croit avoir
trouvé la Martin gale qui lui assurera
la fortune éternelle il a pas lu Gustave
Lebon c'est que finalement le socle du
socle c'est la confiance la valeur au
fond les les choses n'ont pas de valeur
Intrinsec
elles n'ont que la valeur que nous leur
donnons et la valeur que je leur donne
souvent elle est corrélée à la valeur
que vous leur donnez si vous attribuez
de la valeur à quelque chose je vais
être tenté moi de faire la même chose
que vous par une espèce de
mimétisme c'est ça la psychologie des
foules il y a un coup de pétard qui est
tiré au premier étage des Galeries la
faillette bah tout le monde se précipite
en même temps vers la sortie et à
l'inverse vous annoncez des promotions à
- 50 tout le monde se précipite sur le
rayon donc on est conduit comme ça par
là il y a y a il y a une espèce de de de
vraiment de quelque chose de très
fondamental dans la psychologie humaine
qui qui fait que c'est très difficile de
piloter la
finance de façon précautionneuse parce
que les les les embardés sont déterminés
par les deux émotions premières de
l'homme c'est c'est c'est alors un autre
de mes maîtres qui m'a appris ça un
économiste éminent qui s'appelle Marc de
sitivau qui est aujourd'hui un vieux
monsieur et et lui disait finalement il
y a le désir de gagner et la peur de
perdre et c'est ça qui détermine le
fonctionnement des marchés financiers il
y a des moments où c'est le désir de
gagner qui l'emporte et tout le monde
achète achète achète et Tesla vaut un
prix complètement invraisemblable qui
n'a plus rien à voir avec la réalité et
tout le monde justifie développe des
justifications mais oui mais il faut une
économie décarboné aujourd'hui pour un
investisseur la seule porte d'entrée
c'est Tesla donc finalement Tesla vaut
bien le prix des Man qui est le sien
pardon au bout du bout il y a un bilan
il y a des clients il y a des marges
alors pour l'instant tout va bien chaîn
d'approvisionnement évidemment la limite
la limite même physique des des des
matières premières et cetera
donc un jour ou l'autre Tesla seogera un
de ces murs là je ne sais pas lequel et
alors le le le patron est un homme
éminent qui a réussi des tas de choses
hein mais mais euh mais mais attention
euh n'oublions pas que il y a un certain
nombre de
fondamentaux pas parler de rationalité
économique parce que ça fait un peu
péndant et puis euh c'est un mot
d'économiste mais mais c'est du bon sens
plutôt hein c'est c'est c'est la logique
fondamentale et donc si vous voulez euh
je pense que dans cette espèce de jeu tu
me tiens je te tiens par la barbichette
entre les marchés euh les dirigeants euh
politiques et de l'autre côté euh les
banques centrales euh tout tout n'est
pas fini aujourd'hui II c'est les
banques centrales qui ont pris la main
qui disent attention j'ai sorti mon
fusil je tire un coup neu coups bon mais
mais un jour ne augmentations oui c'est
ça je dis neu il me semble que c'est ça
dans dans dans la séquence récente enfin
c'est une dizaine ils ont un petit peu
ralenti là et là là il c'est c'est c'est
bloqué mais le le rapport de force est
en train de changer hein ce sont les
marchés les digents politiques qui
reprennent la main implicitement en
disant sans le dire aux banques
centrales les amis attention si c'est
indépendant mais de loin oui mais
l'indépendance des banques centrales
c'est c'est une c'est une blague c'est
une blague c'est une blague euh
alors en Europe on a on a une un côté un
peu théologique là-dessus à cause de
l'Allemagne qui qui qui voilà qui qui a
une espèce de de qui avait une espèce de
vénération pour sa monnaie pour des
raisons qui n'avait rien d'économique
d'ailleurs mais la monnaie était au fond
le symbole de l'Allemagne reconstruite
après l'éclipse dramatique de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale donc le Deutsch Mark
c'était l'Allemagne démocratique pour
nous ça semble saugrenu on naurait
jamais l'idée de mettre dans la monnaie
notre orgueil national surtout pas
aujourd'hui mais mais donc du coup
l'indépendance de la Banque centrale
c'était au fond le temple la banque
centrale dans lequel on allait célébrer
ce culte de la monnaie je le dis de
façon un peu ironique mais mais il y
avait une certaine noblesse aussi
là-dedans dans le sens où c'était
l'Allemagne qui récusait son passé pour
dire
désormais nous allons de fait les
instruments de notre puissance ne sont
plus militaires mais plutôt commerciaux
et
monétair qui en général très corréé oui
oui tout à fait mais l'indépendance des
banques centrales c'est au fond une une
une illusion parce que les banques
centrales ne sont pas en dehors du
système
et justement elle comme elle elles sont
attentive à la stabilité financière et
aussi à la croissance plus ou moins
suivant les continents la Banque
fédérale américaine la banque centrale
américaine est réputée plus attentive au
niveau de chômage que la Banque centrale
européenne c'est moins vrai aujourd'hui
je pense parce que le poids relatif de
l'Allemagne a diminué dans la Banque
centrale européenne quand on a créé
l'euro le poids de l'Allemagne était
très important pas tant le poids
proportionnel au sens littéral mais le
poids je dirais politique psychologique
au point que même les disons les deux
premiers gouverneurs qui se sont
succédés vim deusenberg et Jean-Claude
Trichet le néerlandais le français était
dans la psychologie allemande pour
rassurer les Allemands hein mais
mais cette indépendance elle elle est
alors elle a été poussée par les marchés
pour des raisons qui ne sont pas très
honorables je
crois parce qu'au
fond à partir du moment où on dit vous
vous vous souvenez du du du du du du
raisonnement c'était de dire finalement
les politiques sont pas sérieux ils
corrompent la monnaie parce qu'ils en
créent dès qu'ils en ont besoin pour
acheter les votes je je raccourc
subordation de vote par le CH exactement
donc c'est un argument qui va très fort
chez les les cryptoonur oui mais oui
mais alors on y revient aujourd'hui j'y
viens dans un instant on on on rend les
banques centrales
indépendante en Europe c'est le traité
de Maastricht qui consacre ça alors on
avait un peu anticipé nous mais enfin
bon en gros c'est mastrich qui s'alignne
sur l'Allemagne euh le en en aux
États-Unis au Royaume-Uni c'était un peu
intérieur puis ça a été consolidé petit
à petitrich passé au forceceps en France
passer au forceps en France avec avec ce
vote riraac en septembre 92 bien sûr
mais donc euh on dit finalement la
monnaie est une chose trop sérieuse pour
les politiques on va la confier à des
vrais experts et on les rend
indépendants au même titre que les
magistrats sont
indépendants parce que il s'agit de
gérer le bien commun qui est la monnaie
de protéger l'épargne des citoyens
autrement dit de ne pas faire
d'inflation
et bon c'est une façon de lire le truc
on peut aussi lire le truc
différemment on peut aussi lire bah
finalement l'indépendance des banqu
centrale la préservation de la valeur de
la monnaie c'est au fond la grande off
offensive des années 80 et 90 du
capital qui veut préserver la valeur de
l'argent et qui du coup se met entre la
les mains d'experts avec une vision
exclusivement financière ou économique
et non plus politique bon je je dis pas
que c'est mon sentiment c'est une
opinion qui m'intéresse aussi elle est
pas enfin il il y a une part de vérité
là-dedans mais pour revenir à votre
remarque sur les cryptonnaaies la
meilleure preuve que l'indépendance
finalement les politiques ont repris la
main au travers des mécanismes qu'on
décrivait il y a un instant crinpan
87 geitner trichait 2008 et
puis le leurs successeurs au moment du
covid en en 2020 de fait la logique
politique a repris le dessus puisqueen
2020 on dit pour des raisons sociale et
politique il faut créer de la monnaie et
et c'est ce qui explique aussi les sorts
des cryptomonnaaies ou les les gars
disent mais attendez nous c'est même pas
politique ni économique c'est un
algorithme donc vous êtes sûr de
conserver la valeur de votre monnaie on
peut avoir quelques doutes là-dessus
mais et puis au
demurant je ne sais pas si on se met
dans la perspective d'un craque qui
toucherait jusqu'à la valeur
fondamentale de la monnaie comment le
Bitcoin et les autres réagiraient je
n'en sais rien je n'en sais rien
honnêtement je pense que c'est
d'ailleurs imprévisible mais tout ça
pour dire que dans le jeu
dans le rapport de force entre le
pouvoir politique et la banque centrale
euh les politiques ont fait de la
résistance et on arrive à l'épreuve de
vérité me semble-t-il c'est-à-dire cette
correction que vous évoquez moi j'évoque
plutôt une grosse branlé quand même non
oui alors c'est c'est c'est moi qui
l'évoquit c'est vous qui utilisiez des
termes plus explicites mais mais peu
importe enfin pas peu importe parce que
le rythme change quand même la la la
chose c'est vrai que si si les marchés
sont comme dans les années 70
c'est-à-dire pas pas très performant
mais mais qu' a pas de d'effondrement
c'est pas la même chose que en en
octobre 2008 où là ça crée un stress sur
le système financier qui est
considérable parce que là aussi on nous
dit les
banques ont renforcé leurs provisions et
cetera les mesures prudentielles bilvesé
sapin 1 sain 2 non balle 1 balle 2 balle
3 les fonds propres des banques en ca
collatéral c'est ça oui qui serait
capable de dééponger des petits c'était
compliqué mais bien sûr c'est comp
Crédit Suisse on l'a senti passer très
très fort là et encore ça a tenu hein ça
a tenu vous vous souvenez qu'il y en a
eu il y a eu quelques petites banques
américaines qui ont été avalées quand
même cré un sacré secousse hein et puis
Crédit Suisse effectivement a été avallé
par l'UBS mais euh à quel prix après a
PRS élevé enfin le système a tenu hein
alors bon il y a des petites alertes ça
et là mais ça ça a tenu et euh mais si
vous voulez ceux qui disent balle 1
balle 2 bal balle 3 il faut les renvoyer
à Gustave Lebon
euh le jour où nous citoyens avons peur
de laisser notre argent à la banque
balle 1 balle 2 balle 3 mon œil hein et
et alors je me souviens et on peut
rajouter une petite phrase avant que
vous vous souveniez le fond de garantie
des dépôts bancairesc fait levier mais
oui c'est mais c'est c'est c'est c'est
le même genre d'illusion tu as la grande
graine mais t'inquiète pas il me reste
du paracétamol dans ma trousse de
toilett c'est ça c'est des systèmes qui
sont bien pour le beau temps hein c'est
c'est des c'est des bateaux de beau
temps donc quand vous il fait beau vous
avez un petit problème de gouvernaille
vous avez le temps de réparer vous
appelez le fond de garantie machin
chouette qui vient vous mettre 10 20 30
50 milliards bon mais par mauvais temps
c'est plus du tout la même limonade
parce que c'est la question de la
confiance qui est là et et oui j'en
étais à vous dire que je me souvenais je
me souviens quand j'ai sorti ce livre
qui s'appelait la crise des années 30 et
devant nous c'était édition pin je l'ai
sorti en mars 2007 la thèse était simple
c'était ça va péter sur les subprimes
parce que c'est une mécanique de Ponzi
donc il y aura une crise financière
grave là-dessus il y aura une crise
grave sur l'euro à cause des dette
publique j'avais raison sur cette partie
làà il y a une troisième partie sur
laquelle j'ai eu tort je me suis trompé
de calendrier c'était il y aura une
crise de l'endettement en Chine j'ai
sous-estimé le mécanisme dont je vous
parlais à l'instant c'estàdire que le
fait que histoire de de construire pour
construire oui c'est ça et qu'on pouvait
il y avait l'ardoise magique qui
permettait d'effacer les des mais sur
les deux premiers points j'avais raison
donc je suis invité pour parler de ce
bouquin qui a une diffusion
confidentielle parce que voilà j'étais
pas encore très connu à l'époque et puis
c'était une thèse ça ça disait on va
avoir une crise bancaire crise bancaire
parce que compte tenu de
l'interpénétration
du système bancaire mondial s'il se
passe un truc à holulu bah à anère on en
perçoit les conséquences et je me
souviens d'un dîner avec d'un déjeuner
où j'étais invité je crois que c'était
l'Institut de l'entreprise qui
était dirigé à l'époque par Michel pebro
si Michel pebro était là en tout cas
c'était le patron de BNP banquier
éminent qui a réussi la fusion BNP
pariba qui a fait BNP paribba géant
bancaire européen qu'il est aujourd'hui
et je me souviens de l'air je
dirais presque charitable ou
condescendant en tout cas c'est un homme
d'une grande intelligence hein avec
lequel il m'a posé la question mais une
crise bancaire monsieur l'anglais mais
mais mais mais mais ça n'est pas
possible alors bon j'ai pédalé un peu
c'était un homme impressionnant qui
savait beaucoup de chose et j'ai essayé
de justifier comme j'ai pu il y avait là
d'ailleurs l'actuel le le patron de
saint-gobin qui s'appelle Pierre-André
de chalandard
et je bon on on en a reparlé
relativement récemment il se trouve il
est aujourd'hui il a quitté
saint-gobin parce que voilà c'est un
homme qui est maintenant à l'âge de la
retraite et il m'a dit mais quand vous
avez dit ça je me suis dit ce type est
un cinglé et et il me dit depuis je fais
beaucoup plus attention à ce que vous
dites parce que je me suis rendu compte
que finalement
euh voilà de temps en temps il y a des
ruptures comme celle-là et et il m'a il
m'a fait l'amitié l'estime du coup de ne
pas prendre pour débvuser ce que ce que
je ce que je dis aujourd'hui je je n'en
tire pas d'avantage parce que il faut
pas c'est un peu le problème de nriel
Robini je crois que vous l'avez reçu
mais euh on l'embrasse d'ailleurs et
mais moi
aussi mais c'est que
finalement l'un de mes maîtres à
l'expansion a une formule formidable
d'ailleurs pour décrire ça c'était
Philippe lefournier qui était
l'économiste qui était le nourriel
rouini des années 80 90 et il disait une
pendule arrêtée donneleur deux fois par
jour autrement dit à force de répéter
toujours la même chose un jour ou
l'autre vous avez raison et et c'est le
le Rubini a eu l'immense mérite de de de
prévoir la crise de 2007 avec beaucoup
plus de précision que je ne l'ai fait
moi moi je dirais c'était une analyse un
peu voilà à la fois sociétale politique
économique transversale et qui s'pp ne
tombez pas à à discréditer votre analyse
non non non mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que je ne me sens pas au niveau de
Robini c'est ce que je veux vous dire
mais que en même temps
Rubini depuis il dit voilà ça va péter
ça va péter ça va péter et
et finalement quand on a eu raison une
fois c'est vrai que c'est tant de
reprendre la même mécanique
psychologique raconte une petite
histoire comme ça on on va on va faire
partager ça à notre communauté il y a
une dizaine d'années je je vaais voir un
un ami qui
était qui a été directeur d'une très
très grande banque de stature
internationale et on fait une discussion
de prospective une expérience de pensée
il me dit écoute si tu as raison ça va
très mal se passer il faut que tu sois
dans une banque qui a l'habitude de
gérer ce type de crise il me fait je te
fais rentrer chez
Rothschild je dis écoute tu es bien
gentil mais c'est pas avec les quatre
CoPc que j'ai que je vais être accepté
chez rothchield il me dit non mais
t'inquiète pas je passe tr de fil tu
rentres chez R ils ont l'habitude de
gérer ce type de crise et je suis
d'accord avec toi que si ça continue
comme ça avec les lunettes roses dans
les agences de notation les lunettes
roses dans les dans les ministères les
lunettes roses dans les conseil
d'administration bancaire on va au
carton et les seules banques qui seront
capables de gérer ce truc là c'est
celles qui ont résisté et de fil en
aiguille on va d'ailleurs pouvoir en
discuter un peu plus tard on parle de
l'immigration des répercussions que ça
peut avoir vous parliez de d'un choc à
Lulu qui arrive jusqu'à anè sursène ça
crée aussi aussi des mouvements de
population quand il y a le dollar qui
est dévalué ça crée des des des
problèmes aussi en Afrique parce que bah
les gens ils peuvent plus bouffer et
donc compliqué donc on discute de temps
en temps et alors c'est vrai que on a
rencontré des grands banquiers qui
étaient totalement aveugles ou qui
prétendaient être bordne ou totalement
aveugle parce que derrière si l'action
de la banque elle continue de monter
derrière ils prennent des petits billets
quand même bien sûr mais bien sûr ont
tout
intérêt que tout va bien et que me de
qui indique la mauvaise heure deux fois
par jour non non j'ai pas dit ça il il
dit au contraire il indique la bonne
heure de fois par jour mais tout à fait
c'est c'est souvent la mauvaise pour t
tous ceux qui ne n'acceptaient pas son
son prisme de lecture le Rubini il s'est
fait avoir comme vous avec l'immobilier
chinois il pensait pas que les banques
centrales étaient complètement folle
d'un goû donc si le système avait été
non pas administré comme un système
soviétique comme à l'heure actuelle les
marchés sont administrés façon
soviétique on parle de contrôle des prix
donc il a deond des loyer euh la totale
et quand on se retrouve avec ça on
coronurise Rubini en disant c'est un
prophète de malheur et puis deux fois
par jour il indique la bonne heure sauf
que lui quand il indique l'heure et
qu'on va se prendre une grosse branlé
avec les arguments qu'il peut tenir dans
ses bouquins on peut évaluer le niveau
de choc qu'on va se prendre dans la tête
est-ce que vous pensez que nos
politiques nos
journalistes sont sous drogue
avec des lunettes roses et que bon ils
sentent que ça pique un peu mais que ça
pique pas tout de suite pour eux et
qu'on continue joyeusement parce qu'on
achète du temps et que vous vous rendez
pas compte c'est un peu le principe des
banques qui se cassent la figure to big
to fail trop gros pour se casser la
figure si on perd la confiance la
stabilité dans l'état c'est l'anarchie
et c'est du sang dans les rues vous
connaissez le proverbe Rothchild qui dit
quand le sang commence à couler dans les
rues il est temps d'investir dans la
pierre alors on sait pas si c'est une
pierre funérale funéraire pardon ou si
c'est investir dans appartement à
l'heure actuelle le marché de
l'immobilier se vautre totalement on n
fait pas encore grand écho mais ça se
votre totalement les prévisions de
lubrifiant industriel pour 2024 sont en
berne on s'attend à ce que l'activité il
y ait moins de demande donc on va se
rattraper une grosse r récession et le
pire c'est que le pétrole baisse alors
tout le monde dit chouette chouette
c'est cool parce qu'on va pouvoir passer
l'hiver pour pas trop cher que quand le
pétrole baisse et que les lubrifiants
ils s'attendent à qu'il a moins de
demande ça veut dire qu'on va vers une
grosse récession est-ce que le temps qui
a été acheté par nos politiques c'était
peut-être un peu trop cher par rapport à
la punition qu'on va se prendre
derrière parce que vous avez les
capacités de faire les interconnexions
avec d'autres domaines
social
environnemental d'investissement dans
des boîtes des répercussions que ça peut
avoir sur le filet
social votre avis sur la situation ça
sent le
sapin fort très fort ou pas très fort je
pense que enfin il y a beaucoup de
choses dans votre question hein euh
d'abord juste un mot sur avant de
répondre au fond on dit bonjour à
Patrick qui Milon qui nous fait un grand
coucou qui est très fan de vous oh ben
écoutez bien sûr qu'on on d'abord on je
suis flatté qui qui s'intéresse à ce que
je dis et et et je le salue bien bien
amicalement euh
non un mot sur
le au fond l'espèce de conformisme je
dirais plutôt un délirum très mince
là je je je n'irai pas jusque là je
pense
que le confort enfin il s'explique de
deux façons d'abord précisément par les
les
mouvements de mimétisme vous avez froid
pas du tout non non non non par les
mouvements de mimétisme et et qui font
que il faut se protéger de ça quand on
est journaliste notamment c'est-à-dire
que en général quand tout le monde dit
le même truc c'est faux c'est pas une
loi absolue
mais vous avez quand même beaucoup plus
de chance de d'être dans le vrai si vous
prenez le contrepied il faut pas en
faire un système mais il faut toujours
garder ça présent à l'esprit ça vaut
pour les journalistes comme tous les
émetteurs pour les chefs d'entreprise
pour les investisseurs évidemment
évidemment et l'autre élément que je
voulais dire là-dessus c'est que par
rapport à votre question et je viens au
fond dans un instant je veux pas du tout
éluder le le truc temps
François Le le le si vous voulez quand
vous êtes commentateur de l'actualité
comme je le suis quotidiennement RTL ou
de façon plus épisodique à TF1 et et à
LCI vous ne pouvez pas être au fond tout
le temps vous ne pouvez pas habiter dans
le fond tout le temps parce que sinon
vous vous perdez aussi le le le
l'intérêt des gens vous pouvez pas les
ramener aux problèmes fondamentaux tout
le temps quelquefois
l'actualité elle est d'un autre ordre et
vous ne pouvez pas euh le le la ramener
à la grande question macrofinancière à
la grande inquiétude macrofinancière je
prends un exemple Renault et Nissan
changent les modalités de leur alliance
aujourd'hui c'est intéressant dans le
rapport de force mais ça ça ne touche
pas la question de fond que vous évoquez
donc je pourrais la commenter demain ça
n'est pas le cas en l'occurrence c'est
pas le sujet que j'ai choisi pour demain
mais mais je veux dire je pourrais
sembler oublieux des grandes questions
euh macro-économique financière en
réalité je suis sur un autre plan vous
voyez ce que je veux dire c'est que vous
avec votre timing c'est-à-dire vous
sélectionnez vos intervenants vous les
faites parler deux ou trois heur
mécaniquement et c'est même votre votre
fond de commerce si je puis dire même
s'il ne s'agit pas d'un commce au sens
littéral vous allez au
fond dans la dans le les médias je
dirais mainstream ceux pour lesquels je
travaille on est
forcément sur différents registres je
pour vous couper oui on est très
critique avec les journalistes vous avec
un peu moins parce que je vais vous
lancer des fleurs c'est pas fait
pour
attention on vous sent un peu
c'est que nous comme vous l'avez
remarqué on bosse les
jusqu'à aller en kikiner les prix Nobel
d'économie vous on vous sent un petit
peu brimé ou un petit peu frustré de pas
pouvoir rentrer dans le détail un peu
plus profondément parce que on sent
quand même que vous avez compris que
c'était la pierre angulaire de la
stabilité de nos sociétés bien sûr quand
vous êtes pédagogue sur 10 minutes de de
TF1 5 minutes RTL vous essayez de
passionner les gens à essayer de vous
intéresser à essayer de les intéresser
sur ce sujet c'est très bien soyez
indulgent avec vous quand même parce que
dit comme
vous vous êtes charitable je je vous je
je me permets de vous interrompre sur
TF1 l'unité de base un papier d'un édito
de François Langlais c'est une minute 15
c'est pas 10 minutes donc en 1 minute 15
il faut trouver le
moyen de donner un peu le sous-jacent
d'une
question de
dire par exemple sur ces questions d'
inflation de pouvoir d'achat je l'ai
fait à plusieurs reprises dans l'année
révolue bah un l'inflation est plutôt
causée par les marges des entreprises
hein que par l'augmentation des salaires
et c'est quand même une bizarrerie à
laquelle il faut s'intéresser surtout
dit sur TF c'est beau oui mais écoutez
c'est la vérité alors après mon problème
moi c'est de faire cours à partir de
sujets compliqués mais et je pense que
vous serez d'accord avec
moi j'ai remarqué quand même que dans un
problème compliqué souvent ce qu'il y a
de plus important c'est ce qu'il y a de
plus simple rasoir de Cam oui
l'explication la plus simple est souvent
la meilleure mais oui mais oui c'est le
rapport de force donc je peux je peux
synthétiser ce qui se passe en ce moment
on est dirigé par une cast
autosélectionné qui s'est bien assis sur
certaines fonctions il voit pas les
choses venir ils ont pas l'intention de
faire changer leur propre système ils
continuent à faire des chèqus avec le
chquier de Mami France pour éponger
leurs conneries des 40 dernières années
c'est une explication suffisamment
simple ou c'est un petit peu trop c'est
à coup de c'est à coup de ser ouis j'y
suis pas all encore au bazooka non non
je vous connais pas mais je je commence
à voir est-ce que l'asile est piloté par
les les foles dingot en fait je crois
que là
encore il y
a il y a c'est c'est exactement les
mêmes deux choses que je j'équéis tout à
l'heure c'està-dire le conformisme
c'estàd bon ils sont dans ce monde
là on est dans ce monde là je peux m
dedans donc par moment il faut vraiment
prendre un peu de recul historique ou
élargir la focale pour comprendre que ce
Mondel d'abord il n'a pas toujours
existé comme ça
deuxièmement il va probablement pas
continuer comme ça donc ça c'est le
conformisme et et le le deuxième élément
vous le pointez en filigrane avec ce que
vous dites c'est les intérêts c'est les
intérêts quand on est dans une position
où dont on profite quel qu'en soi les
modalités je parle pas forcément de
profit financier mais il y a aussi du
profit financier vous parlez d'un un
financier qui va vous dire c'est la
crise financière moi j'en connais
quasiment pas j'en connais quasiment pas
parce que les types n'ont pas intérêt à
tuer la poule auor ils ont intérêt à ce
que tous les gogos continuent d'arriver
hein pour acheter leurs trucs et cetera
donc donc il y a aussi l'intérêt si vous
additionnez le le le le le le poids du
conformisme et celui des intérêts vous
arrivez au fait que les décisions ne
sont pas toujours prises je voudrais
quand même ajouter une chose à ce que
vous dites parce que vous dites cast on
peut contester le mot pas beaucoup la
réalité il y a une élite c'est sûr bien
sûr
les subprime c'était très élitiste quand
même comme Arnac non
ouais encore que pour le coup il y a des
municipalité de Norvège je me souviens
qui avait placé l'argent de leur petit
vieux là-dedans et P ils sont fait a les
petit vieux hongrois qui avait souscrit
des taux variables aussi exactement oui
oui c'est ça en ce sens là c'est souvent
les petits gens qui sont victimes des on
demande comment Orban a été élu
d'ailleurs ça c'est encore autre chose
mais ce que je voulais vous dire c'est
que euh dans ce mondelà reprenez le
l'exemple que je vous donnais tout à
l'heure c'estàdire le quoiquil en coude
pendant le covid
euh tout le monde en a profité hein tout
le monde le restaurateur du coin là vous
si vous avez sûrement discuter avec lui
moi j'étais sidéré par le nombre de
restaurateurs qui me disaient
franchement là le gouvernement il a bien
fait les choses là on peut pas dire il y
en a qui le qui finissaient par le dire
ils ont quasiment jamais gagné autant
d'argent qu'à ce moment-là euh zéro coup
fixe et puis les les les subventions
diverses et variées donc c'était encore
une foisà on allait pas les laisser
crever d'accord ce que je veux dire
c'est que de ce point de vue la
responsabilité elle est collective alors
vous allez me dire le restaurateur il
est pas forcément au courant de tous les
déterminants d'où vient l'argent les
banques centrales sans doute mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que le profit généré
par ce système il est sans doute
concentré en haut de la pyramide avec la
finance qui en en récupère une bonne
partie hein donc un petit groupe de de
gens en terme numérique si on compare à
la population mondiale rusellement
inversé oui il y a un peu de ça il y a
un peu de ça mais mais le le il y a
quand même eu des bénéfices beaucoup
plus larges aussi hein et que cétait
fictif combien il y a d'entreprises
zombies qui sont en train de caloncher
non non c'est vrai bien sûr bien sûr
mais qui avait la conscience de ça à
l'époque les vieux disait donnez-nous de
l'argent vous en avez donné au
restaurateur moi je suis réparateur de
semelle j'en ai pas eu autant et
souvenez-vous de de de voilà du délire
administratif qui a été mis en uvre à
cel ça reflétait quoi ça reflétait une
grande peur de l'État ça reflétait quoi
de se faire juger par une population qui
constate leur vacuité oh je pense que ça
ça reflétait quoi une perte de
déclassement à l'échelle mondiale ça
reflétait la peur d'avoir une population
qui était en train de creer dans les
hôpitaux pas suffisamment dimensionné
qui avait été séché et SAÉ depuis une
vingtaine d'années en diminuant leurs
effectifs en comprenant que l'hôpital en
fin compte c'était pas un business pas
comme un
autre ça reflète quoi en fait est-ce
qu'on est
gouverné administré même par des gens
qui fonctionnent bien que par beau temps
des capitaines de pédalo qui là commence
à se prendre deux trois petits grains
alors je vous parle même pas de
l'Atlantique connaissez un peu la
Méditerranée un petit peu la
Méditerranée quand elle commence à
s'énerver elle s'énerve c'est très
violent est-ce que là on a pas des
capitaines de pédalo à l'ouest total si
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai de ce
point de vue là c'est vrai que
l'élection de Macron en 2017 et se fait
sur un programme globalement assez
libéral startup et cetera c'est un
programme de beau
temps l'élevage de licorne il faut du
beau temps oui alors bon c'est très bien
les start-up enfin je veux dire c'est
indispensable ça n'aurait pas une nation
quand même hein et surtout pas par
mauvais temps précisément donc de ce
point de vue il y a il y a une un
décalage entre la psychologie la culture
l'histoire de la génération qui est au
pouvoir aujourd'hui et ce qui se
présente et à mon avis ce qui se
présente pour les années qui viennent
mais il faut pas oublier quand même et
là l'histoire est d'un grand secours
encore une fois c'est pas la première
fois que des périodes comme ça se
produit la dernière fois période un peu
similaire c'est les années 30 on est
ressorti comment alors mal
mais juste je termine de vous répondre
là-dessus dans les années
30 c'est exactement le problème que vous
décrivez c'est-à-dire que il y a des
gens qui sont convaincu qu'on va revenir
au système d'avant1 c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que on remet en route les
talons or et cetera c'est plutôt dans
les années 20 mais ça ça se poursuit un
peu dans les années 30 malgré les
tremblements de plus en plus fort la
montée du nazisme et cetera donc les
élites ne sont pas du tout équipées pour
les temps qui se présentent mais il y a
quand même des gens qui sont nés et qui
sont là et qui vont reprendre le bazar
Churchill est
considéré
disons au moment où il arrive au pouvoir
dans à la fin des années 30 comme un
raté hein on considère qu'il a raté sa
carrière parce que les les dardanel le
désastre militaire parce que il a fait
rentrer justement la livre sterling à
une parité trop élevé dans les années 20
et que la Liv sterling a été obligé de
de de dévaluer au début des années 30 et
pourtant et pourtant c'est lui qui
redresse le pays qui le conduit à la
victoire donc ce que je veux dire c'est
que
très probablement on ne les voit pas
mais c'est parce que nous ne regardons
pas bien les churcheld aujourd'hui ils
sont nés et ils sont au boulot je peux
vous casser vos rêves de boomer oui oui
oui tout le respect que je vous dois la
crise de 30 39 45 70 toutes les crises
qu'on traversé quel est le dénominateur
commun de toutes ces crises comment on
s'en est
sorti celle des années
30 le je dirais la lecture
conventionnelle c'est la guerre on dit
c'est la guerre qui a permis de régler
ça euh quand on regarde de près j'ai
beaucoup travaillé sur cette
période c'est c'est c'est pas faux la
guerre a pardonnez-moi deux
vertus à côté des désastres
qu'ellepporte
elle détruit du capital et il faut le
reconstruire après et elle renouvelle
les élites de façon très brutale
regardez ce qui s'est passé en 45 les
gars qui redressent la France c'est le
paysan du coin et l'aristocrate qui
sétait retrouvé dans les réseaux de la
résistance tout est bouleversé parce que
la guerre détruit aussi du capital
social elle tue les gens et donc les
réseaux disparaissent d'autres se
reconstituent ils se nouent face à
l'épreuve c'est le courage qui compte du
coup l'élite qui sort n'est plus du tout
la même donc là-dessus la guerre a joué
son rôle
c'est c'est beaucoup plus simple que ça
mais je vous laisse continuer he
euh pour autant je pense que
euh il y a des crises très voisines à
celles qu'on a connu à celles que nous
connaissons antérieur qui n'ont pas été
résolu par la guerre et et et notamment
euh euh la la la crise avant avant la
belle époque là euh
euh entre euh oui aux alentours de ce
qu'on ce qu'on a appelé la la je crois
qu'on a appelé ça la Grande Dépression à
partir du craque de de 73
1873 bon il y a bien eu une guerre entre
la France et l'Allemagne mais pour le
reste on s'en est sorti autrement parce
que on a renouvelé les élites de façon
différente donc je pense que la guerre
n'est pas le point de d'aboutissement
nécessaire même si quel est le
dominateur commun de toutes ces sorties
de crise alors je sa pas c'est
l'augmentation de la consommation
énergétique donc on s'est toujours sorti
d'une récession d'un choc pétrolier
d'une crise financière d'un covid de ce
que vous voulez par une augmentation de
consommation énergétique et on pourra
pas le faire cette fois-ci et on pourra
pas le faire cette fois-ci si mis à part
ilon de musk ou Bruno Lemer nous sort
des fagot un super brevet pour faire de
l'électricité ou de l'hydrogène à bon
marché on est en train de se renseigner
jusqu'au jour d'aujourd'hui on tombe que
sur de la fumisterie donc là au jour
d'aujourd'hui le bon technologique n'y
est pas les capacités
d'approvisionnement énergétique en
densité comme en qualité n'y sont plus
là si on se prend une vague dans la tête
et qu'on a capitaine de pédal wiioui 1
capitaine de pédal WiiWii 2 et ces tris
numéro 3 qui a lieu qu'il leur ressemble
comme des gouttes d'eau on fait quoi les
chocs vont ressembler à quoi en terme
d'alimentation de logistique de calme de
violence aux personnes d'accidentogène
d'espérance de vie de
démographie ça ressemble à
quoi c'est une question à laquelle on
peut pas répondre c'est démographie ça
se casse la gueule oui non que ce que la
violence aux personnes on peut pas dire
que ça se casse la gueule ça se casse
pas la gueule
ouais non ce que ce que je voulais dire
quand même par rapport à
l'énergie faut pas non plus sous-estimer
le l'inventivité humaine alors c'est un
acte de foi hein c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans le dans le
bleu hein vous croyez en a un ami
imaginaire
pardon un ami vous avez un ami
imaginaire non vous priez vous allez à
l'église à la mosquée ou au temple
quelque chose non en fait ma culture est
celle d'un catholique mais je ne suis
pas pratiquant à poosta même pas non
plus non non donc vous ne croyez pas au
dieu économique non mais c'est marrant
parce que j'étais exactement en train de
penser au Paris de
Pascal c'est-à-dire que finalement
Pascal nous dit on sait pas si Dieu
existe mais on a qu'à faire comme s'il
existait parce que au pire on aura pas
perdu grand-chose je pense que le le le
la foi dans l'inventivité humaine c'est
un peu du même ordre c'est-à-dire que
vous n'avez pas la certitude qu'on va
trouver il y a une certitude quand même
c'est la productivité hein c'est-à-dire
queon consomme moins d'énergie par unité
de PIB que il y a 50 ans
alors par rapport à 50 ans on est le
même nombre avec la même capacité à
consommer l'énergie ou pas parce que en
fait c'est à peu près le problème de la
voiture à 2 L d'essence de chez tatin en
Inde parce que ça sur le papier ça
consomme moins mais si vous en avez s'il
y en a plus ça change l'équation d'ord
non non sans doute écoutez là-dessus les
déterminants sont tellement nombreux que
bien malin peut prévoir ce qui va se
passer mais
que là aussi si vous voulez bon vous
êtes journaliste économique on va à la
pêche
d'accord on va on va faire la pêche à l'
puisette par exemple dans la baie du
Mont sa-michel bon vous avez plus
d'expérience que moi la pêche au Moule
vous connaissez très bien vous regardez
le ciel vous regardez le vent vous la
marée et là vous me dites d'ici 35
minutes ça va se
gâter là vous le sentez comment le temps
qui nous arrive c'est pour prévenir des
gens qui sont en pédalou en ce moment là
vous franchement j'ai regardé votre
parcours vous êtes quand même un peu
plus affuté que la moyenne des
journalistes qui s'occupent de ces
sujets relativement arid et
chiant le temps c'est drapeau jaune
drapeau vert drapeau rouge ou drapeau
noir le temps se
couvre le temps se couvre on voit que
les choses tout tous dérègl un peu en
même temps ce mais j'allais
diregle excusez-moi ça se dérègle parce
que vous ne comprenez pas ce qui se
passe et vous dites que c'est un
dérèglement ou ça change de nature ah
non j'ai l'impression qu'on on comprend
à peu près ce qui se
passe en économie on en a parlé on a ce
plomb de l'hypothèque financière qu'il
faudra liquider un jour ou l'autre il
faudra mais la nouelle la nouveauté des
temps actuels c'est la géopolitique où
là on est dans un autre univers si vous
voulez et là encore l'histoire est d'un
grand secours mais on peut interpréter
ces deux guerres qui sont déclenché à 18
mois
d'écart l'Ukraine en février
22 Israël en octobre 23 elles ont
chacune leurs particularités
historique pas les comparer
mais n'allons pas sur leur
particularités mais au fond allons
plutôt sur ce qui les lit d'un certain
côté c'est la même
histoire c'est
l'histoire de la contestation d'un
certain ordre mondial qui était imposé
par l'Occident et son chef de fil l'AM
l'Amérique a été le maître du monde
pendant à peu près un siècle ça date de
la première guerre mondiale avec une
période de domination incroyable entre
la chute du mur et la guerre d'Ukraine
l'hyperpissance américaine disait
Vedrine et
aujourd'huion il
disait je ne sais pas je laiss terminer
et et aujourd'hui le leadership
américain est
contesté l'Amérique donne le sentiment
de ne plus être à même d'assumer son
rôle de maître du monde du coup tous les
méchants se réveillent hein c'est-à-dire
on a le Russe on a le coréen du Nord on
a l'Iranien et
cetera le Hamas pas encore
ouis notre pauvre roi des bges on
l'embrasse mais du coup
euh c'est c'est ça qui provoque ce
désordre tant qu'il y a un maître du
monde qui fait peur deux choses se
produitisent
un les méchants restent dans leur
terrier de l'économie se mondialise
parce que quand il n'y a plus de risque
géopolitique les entreprises profitent
de la liberté pour aller faire fabriquer
en Patagonie ou vendre en oubékistan
elles peuvent le faire sans risque du
jour au lendemain on a vu ça en 1989
quand le mur de Berlin est tombé la
mondialisation commence le 9 novembre
1989 en réalité il y a deux événements
qui super pose à ce moment-là c'est la
chute du mur de Berlin qui donne à
penser Fukuyama et cetera que c'est la
fin de l'histoire que le libéralisme et
les la démocratie ont gagné et puis
l'intégration de la Chine dans
l'économie mondiale qui elle aussi d'un
certain côté fait un acte de déférence
vis-à-vis du système capitaliste
puisqu'elleadopte et et et elle noue un
partenariat étroit avec les États-Unis
de plus en plus étroit au point de
devenir son premier fournisseur et
cetera donc quand il il y a un maître du
monde il y a mondialisation et il y a
une relative paix mais à partir du
moment où le maître du monde est
contesté généralement par le maître du
monde d'après et bien tous des règles
parce que les conflits régionaux se
développe et que chacun essaie de
reconstituer son empire c'est exactement
à ça qu'on assiste ça a des conséquences
économiques considérables la
mondialisation c'est fini et c'est fini
pas pour 3 ans c'est c'est fini pour 30
ans hein et parce que on va voir se
reconstituer des petites mondialisations
aux frontière politique dans le dialogue
entre la politique et l'économie c'est
la politique qui prédomine toujours on a
pu croire le contraire mais c'était un
moment où justement nous ne voyions pas
nous occidentaux que la politique nous
la dominions via la superpuissance
américaine mais dès lors que celle-ci
est contestée on se rend compte on dit
ah bah oui maintenant c'est le règne du
droit qui contesté par la force non les
gars c'est pas ça auparavant c'était
notre force qui prévalait et et le Sud
global comme on disait pouvait dire ah
c'est le règne du droit qui est contesté
par la force celle des Occidentaux et ça
s'inverse en ce moment vous savez que
tout ça encore ça doit être situé dans
une focale assez large pour des raisons
assez mystérieuses que je ne peux pas
expliquer les maîtres du monde se
succède dans l'histoire du capitalisme
on a commencé avec l'Italie en 1400 en
80 hein et puis après pardon 1492 alors
1492 c'est vraiment le début de la
mondialisation pour le coup la première
avec les grandes expéditions bien sûr
mais enfin d'Illes ça commence un petit
peu avant
mais après on a eu l'Espagne le Portugal
les Pays-Bas la France hein 1815 on se
fait étendre et puis le siècle
britannique évidemment qui se termine
avec la Première Guerre mondiale les
Britanniques cèdent la place aux
États-Unis qui ne cesse de monter
jusqu'à la deuxième guerre mondiale qui
les consacre comme première puissance
guerre froide espèce de parenthèse et
puis chute du mur de Berlin et hyper
puissance américaine guerre d'Ukraine
qui sonne la fin de tout ça et et
alors quel peut être le prochain maître
du monde évidemment il y a la Chine qui
est là et si les méchants se réveillent
c'est pas seulement parce que les
États-Unis ratent leur départ
d'Afghanistan et le l'opère de façon
calamiteuse visiblement ça a joué dans
les motivations de Poutine il s'est dit
ces gars là c'est c'est
épouvantable ils ne savent plus faire la
guerre mais c'est parce qu'il y a un
contre maître du monde possible qui est
la Chine et que tout le monde comprend
bien qu'il y a un affrontement qui se
joue entre les deux superpuissances et
que si on conteste l'une mécaniquement
l'autre se rangera de notre côté c'est
ce qui se passe avec la guerre d'Ukraine
évidemment avec l'axe Pékin Moscou c'est
ce qui se passe aussi en Israël avec
Hamas terin Teron Moscou Pékin c'est la
même ligne c'est la même ligne donc
c'est ça en fait le sujet central qui
s'impose à l'économie mais
évidemment la question d'après c'est la
Chine peut-elle être le maître du monde
al juste avant de passer à la question
d'après la Chine peut être maître du
monde ou
pas l'Europe chez nous quoi on va
continuer de se faire dépesser encore
longtemps sur l'hôtel de la
mondialisation histoire queil se partage
nos restes on va décider un petit peu de
se relever le nez d'enlever les lunettes
de soleil rose et de faire bon écouter
les gamins dans ça suffit vos conneries
où on est cuit et on est condamné à se
faire déper le le le lead politique il
n'y est pas le lead défensif il n'y est
pas la guerre économique il sont tous en
train d'apprendre le le vocabulaire très
récemment donc pour nous c'est cuit on
va ressembler au Portugal de 1960 c'est
caricaturé mais ça y ressemble quand
même non c'est que les États-Unis vont
se partager no rest Chine va se partager
norest et nous on va être un nomansland
on a pas d'énergie on a même plus d'idée
on est en première ligne des des des
flux migratoire puis la démographie la
démographie en berne un système social
qui est basé sur des algorithmes qui ne
sont plus
d'actualité une population étrangère qui
ne s'intègre pas donc la stabilité de
notre système social on peut s'asseoir
dessus il faut un jour ou l'autre en
tant qu'Européen et français dire les
choses soit so on accepte de se faire
taillader soit on fait un peu les
Français à monter en haut du tas de fumi
à 5h du matin essayer de réveiller tout
le monde comme le coq les deux pieds
dans le caca
ou soit on fait comme les Portugais on
se
barre écoutez fait viv le pays comme les
Libanais ont fait avec la diaspora
libanaise est-ce qu'il y a encore une
chance vous dites les portugais mais
c'est aussi le cas des Grecs c'est le
cas des italiensû c'est le cas des
Espagnols bien sûr en fait tous les gens
qualifiés d'Europe du Sud partent
généralement en Europe du Nord
d'ailleurs c'est d'ailleurs assez dingue
parce que finalement en Europe enfin
c'est une autre façon de dire ce que
vous dites mais les vieux du Nord
descendent au sud pour leur retraite
pour avoir du soleil et les jeunes du
Sud montent au nord pour avoir du
travail quoi l'Europe c'est plus très
vrai avec les Anglais a vu non alors les
Anglais ils sont un peu en dehors ils
ont maintenant leur propre le brexit le
brexit sont Baris du Portugal ça
revenait trop
cher
[Musique]
le l'Europe c'est un naire de beau temps
hein la construction européenne
j'entends du moins dans sa version
moderne qui est celle du grand
marché le grand marché c'est l'idée
qu'en abaissant les
frontières le bénéfice
collectif sera le
meilleur c'est une idée complètement
démonée par la réalité hein
et
aujourd'hui je pense tout le monde ne
pense pas comme moi mais qu'on a besoin
de frontière on un de protectionnisme ou
avec du protectionnisme avec du
protectionnisme alors là encore pour
parler des années 30 il y a une
explication classique de la guerre qui
dit le protectionnisme nous mène à la
guerre ce sont des bvusés hein je
pardonnez-moi je je quand on est face à
des gens qui ne jouent pas le jeu et
c'est le cas de de la Chine notamment il
faut se protéger voilà
et investir dans des filières
industrielles d'excellence sans mettre
des protections aux frontières c'est
mettre de l'argent au feu hein dans la
cheminée par brasser c'est ce qu'on a
fait avec les panneaux
solaires les Chinois ont liquidé la
filière c'est ce qui risque de se passer
avec les éoliennes c'est ce qui risque
de se passer avec la voiturein alors la
commission change un petit peu quand
quand même d'approche mais mais c'est
lent c'est prudent
donc mais alors on comprend bien en même
temps c'est c'est là où c'est si vous
voulez le le sujet est plus subtil qu'
n'y paraît c'est que l'Europe s'est
construite sur la négation des frontière
pour oublier la guerre avec une certaine
noblesse l'idée que finalement l'autre
n'est jamais complètement un autre et
que entre Français et Allemands on doit
pouvoir se réconcilier et cetera vous
coupez vous avez aucune visée politique
aucune vous êtes encarté quelque part
pas du tout très bien vous pouvez
continuer pas du tout et je ne le serai
je pense que je ne serai jamais et en
tout cas je ne ferai jamais de politique
euh l'autre n'est jamais tout à fait un
autre c'est c'est le le le voilà le le
truc de base de l'Europe c'est bien pour
le beau temps mais quand justement le
monde tel qu'on vient de le décrire est
en train de se reconstituer avec des
zones
des empires politiques agressifs qui
défendent leur territoire qui veulent
l'agrandir et qui veulent le faire aussi
sur le plan de l'économie il faut
s'organiser alors pour vous dire la
vérité j'ai eu un espoir au moment du
covid quand même parce que on a vu
l'Europe s'équiper collectivement avec
les vaccins on a pas vu la même chose
nous hein on a vu une Europe qui se
pouillit sur les tarmacs pour se voler
les masques c'était vrai au début après
ça ça ça n'a pas été le cas honnêtement
après ils ont négocié ensemble les
contrats des vaccins ah j'ai j'ai pas vu
la lettre de fait l'approvisionnement a
été mutualisé non sérieusement pas dans
le premier temps vous avez raison il y a
eu effectivement la bagarre sur le béton
mais mais mais après oui et de fait
l'Europe est quand même a été le
continent le mieux vacciné ou presque
hein et
et c'est peut-être une grosse connerie
d'ailleurs je pense pas
mais je pense que pour le coup je parle
pour l'achat mutualisé des vaccins
comment ça s'est passé en terme de
contrat on a jamais eu le détail alors
ça c'est encore un autre sujet euh mais
si vous voulez il y a eu un début de
mise en commun dans une période de grand
risque quoi au fond hein et puis après
ça a été décliné de façon un peu mal à
droite avec ce programme de de des des
800 milliards de prêts pour enfin de
prêts pas tous des prêts d'ailleurs pour
reconstruire l'économie européenne de
façon ça a été fait à la façon
européenne c'estàdire de façon très
bureaucratique et je le crains pas très
efficace quoi mais il y a eu au moins un
début de prise de conscience que il
suffisait pas de d'organiser
l'abaissement des frontières et le
retrait de l'État pour que tout se passe
au
mieux le problème c'est exactement comme
pour la question climatique face à
l'innovation humaine c'est une question
de de temps quoi est-ce que l'Europe ira
assez vite dans cette
conversion on peut d'autant plus en
douter que on est quand même 27 et que
tout le monde n'a pas les mêmes idées
là-dessus la question militaire par
exemple de la
défense la gestion des flux migratoires
aussi la gestion des flux migratoires
évidemment sujet Tony Truant alors
j'observe comme vous que tous les pays
du Nord de l'Europe sont en train de
changer hein le Danemark de
renationaliser en réalité leur politique
d'accueil des étrangers c'est la
réalité une autre formulation c'est dire
merde à l'Europe oui oui oui oui quand
l'Allemagne hier dit on va rétablir les
les contrôles aux frontières nationales
elle dit merde à l'Europe oui oui oui
absolument ce que la France jusqu'ici se
refuse à faire hein la France l'a fait
quand même elle n'a pas eu à le faire
jusqu'au bout parce que finalement elle
a obtenu l'assentiment général sur le
marché de l'électricité il y a il y a 15
jours d'ailleurs ça ça tient pourquoi ça
le marché command l'électricité avec
l'Espagne qui est plus dedans le
Portugal qui est plus dedans alors
justement là les règles ont changé hein
et elles vont s'adapter la France va
pouvoir elle y travaille j'ai lu ça dans
le journal tout à l'heure mettre en
place un système national de
tarification nationale à partir des
contraintes de l'usager hein
d'approvisionnement et des contraintes
de DF qui doit à la fois porter une
dette de de 65 milliards d'euros je
crois que c'est la dette la plus
importante des sociétés européennes
probablement pas très loin de celle de
euh Patrick Dr
euh je plaisante mais c'est pas une
plaisanterie pas ce genre de blague et
euh et puis de les contraintes
d'investissement pour investir dans un
nouvel outil de production donc là la
France va pouvoir s'organiser mais de
fait la France a attendu d'avoir le
tampon de l'Europe pour pouvoir mettre
en place sa politique nationale mais
vous voyez que sur tous les sujets ça
commence à apparaître ça c'est attention
ou l'Europe se met d'accord ça marche
quelque foois les vaccins ou l'Europe se
met pas d'accord et les amis à ce
moment-là il faut qu'on s'équipe tout
seul parce que on ne peut pas attendre
donc par gros temps il y a une
expression consacré qui dit chacun son
fut et Dieu pour
tous là ça son un peu la dislocation
géopolitique mondiale mis à part le fait
que les Russes ont réussi à rapprocher
quelques nations d'un côté et quelques
autrre nation de l'autre ça ressemble à
une dislocation géopolitique ouais le
gros temps qui est en face de nous
pénurie matières premières pénurie
énergétique ou du moins trouble
d'approvisionnement sur l'énergie
perturbation de la chaîne logistique
perturbation des services publics d à la
rupture d'approvisionnement au manque de
ressources ouais de ressources on a une
population depuis à peu près 50 ans qui
vit sur les dividendes de la
paix cette formule consacrée pour
rebondir sur votre parallèle avec
l'Europe là on c'est là c'est force 7
qu'on est qu'on voit débarquer là et et
on voit Bruno Le
Maire Bruno Le Maire il a pas trop une
tête de pirate quand
même il il a euh peut-être un petit
moussaillon mais pas je le vois pas en
pirate pouruno le mer vous savez c'est
que je vous disis sur Churchill je sais
pas si Bruno le mer et Churchill mais
mais euh les gens se révèlent parfois
dans les situations hein et il faut
souhaiter que ça soit le cas pour nous
que ça soit d'ailleurs les les gens qui
sont au gouvernement aujourd'hui ou
d'autres c'est possible qu'il y en ait
d'autres c'est même probable qu'il y en
ai d'autres mais
euh le maire il y a au moins un sujet
sur lequel je trouve il est en phase
avec les besoins actuels c'est le forï
pardon non pas les hïes c'est le
le le forcing qui fait pour
réindustrialiser le pays ça c'est
nouveau non non il y a une différence
entre faire un forcing productif et
faire du bruit avec sa bouche agiter les
bras ne soyez pas trop
sévèreut ch bien il faut être exigeant
je suis d'accord avec vous mais mais on
voit quand même des usines arriver on
voit quand même des usines arrivver et
le nucléaire derrière on voit
panierunché pour la magie pour le pays
pour le coup ENF vous mettez dans dans
la situation inconfortable pour moi
d'avoir défendre le gouvernement ça
n'est pas habituel mais non non non j'ai
j'ai eu exactement cette même réaction
en défendant Macron à la suite d'une
nveau chronique sur la taxe
professionnelle c'est vrai donc VO donc
on échange mais sur le nucléaire c'est
typique de ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure sur l'Europe c'est-à-dire que
pour avoir attendu l'Europe la France a
tardé là dans les deux dernières années
auparavant il y a eu d'autres
attermoements qui nétaient pas du tout
liés à l'Europe qui était lié au fait
que Macron a changé d' vie hein
et tout au début de son quinquena du
premier quinena il est encore dans la
lancée il faut diminuer la part du
nucléaire en France c'est la lancée
François Hollande à la fois pour des
raisons politique avoir le vote
écologiste et puis avec l'idée un peu
naïve que finalement on pourra trouver
des sources de d'énergie de substitution
en mettant des éoliennes et des panneaux
solaires quoi hein et euh non non mais
là c'est une erreur de de de de de
diagnostique et d'analyse terrible
débutant de débutant elle est en tout
cas extrêmement regrettable me qui a
jamais visité une
Assyrie sans doute il aurait vu que ça
consommait énormément mais regardez il y
a presque encore plus terrible hein
c'est Merkel euh qui met des moulins
avant partout on se dit ça suffira et
puis le gaz russe he donc les les les
deux se trouvent complètement hypothéqué
en l'espace de de de peu de temps le
collier et
laal le collier chinois laal russe oui
oui tout à fait tout à fait mais alors
les deux sont d'ailleurs en disons en
pleine
transformation comment vous expliquez le
fait que les Allemands nous tire en même
temps dans les pattes du nucléaire par
un XY moutage pour influencer notre
politique intérieure je pense que c'est
pas du tout l'argument écologique c'est
un argument de
compétitivité c'est beau l'Europe depuis
toujours l'industrie allemande considère
que le nucléaire donne à la France un
avantage compétitif
indu DEP depuis toujours donc
aujourd'hui on a une administration
allemande avec le chanceel leschols qui
est beaucoup plus dur hein bien que sa
coalition soit branlante dur sur quoi
par rapport à la France aus ah oui je je
l'ai rencontré une fois j'étais c'est un
homme très profond hein
très qui réfléchit avant de parler c'est
un en bourgeois c'est donc c'est
l'Allemagne du Nord con Hambourg
l'histoire d'Hambourg non pas enfit j'y
suis passé mais mais euh lutérien là-bas
oui oui bien sûr puis c'est des
commerçants he c'est la h donc mais
mais il y a pas du tout de de de
salamalek pour la France he c'est c'est
chacun pour soi et il considère lui et
un certain nombre de de dirigeants
allemands que l'Allemagne est le sentre
de l'Europe que l'Allemagne est
l'économie la plus puissante et que de
ce fait là elle doit réjentter un peu le
le collectif la France se bat évidemment
surtout sur la question du nucléaire qui
est identitaire et
là-dessus pardonnez-moi mais il y a
quand même du boulot qui a été fait
parce que ils obtiennent là il y a 15
jours la possibilité de construire le
cadre réglementaire et juridique qui
si on se dépêche permettront de de de
permettra de de de rénover l'outil
nucléaire et nous protéger un peu des
pénuries que vous a autoriser à être un
petit peu plus la serpette h bon ok ils
ont fait tomber le pot de sauce tomate
sur le tapis
ok bon ils se dépêchent de nettoyer mais
derrière on a 18h de route pour aller à
l'autre bout de la France c'est pas un
peu tard ça c'estàd que c'est bien beau
de réagir au pied du mur c'est bien beau
de réagir quand on s'est pris le mur
qu'on a rebondi un peu dessus qu'on se
dit ou ou ou ou ou il y a la remorque
qui arriveer derrière il y a un retard
qui est important ça vient de quoi ce
retard ça vient du fait queil y a pas de
cellules d'anticipation qui font pas de
prospective qui sont pas connectés avec
les réalité qui's ont aucune notion de
soutenabilité d'une société
thermoindustrielle sur une croissance
exponentielle ça vient de quoi parce
que plus on se penche sur le sujet plus
on essaie de faire venir les politiques
bon les politiques qui sont à
l'industrie qui sont au ministère de
Bercy ils savent que ici il vont se
faire vaporiser réduit à l'état de
pochoir vous les sous-estimez un peu non
on connait ber on AAD dans le lo on a
même fait un petitour tour façon mission
impossible sur l'éipor qui a été
construit où ils sont posés deux fois
dessus qui a coûté 10 milliards pour
rien mais bon ça faisait plaisir avec
notre poignon c'est toujours mieux donc
le gros temps on le voit bienvenir vous
êtes journaliste vous intéressez à tout
un tas de trucs ça se voit dans vos
chroniques vous êtes un des seul à
bosser
correctement on va on va se parler de
professionnel à professionnel ils sont
quoi ils sont mauvais ils anticipent
rien ils font des conneries on dis c'est
pas de ma faute c'est la faute du prédc
sœur on va où on va où ils sont où les
grands hommes politiques ils sont tous
en train de tenir leur petit parquet on
les voit à espag raché qui fait des
grandes annonces le nucléaire on va
engager des milliers de
personnes c'est trop
tard c'est tard c'est pas trop tard mais
je pense que il
raisonne beaucoup en court terme et à la
façon d'un politique c'est-à-dire en en
considérant beaucoup l'opinion comment
elle va
réagir du coup le
déterminant présent si vous voulez quand
dans toute décision vous avez les
obstacles présents et puis
l'anticipation et les avantages que vous
escomptez sur l'avenir c'est la question
de tout investissement vous devez sortir
de l'argent et vous escomtez un bénéfice
à 5 ou 10 ans 5 ou 10 ans pour eux c'est
loin et de ce point de vue il y a eu un
raccourcissement de l'horizon temporel
qui qui est à l'œuvre depuis je pense
une quinzaine d'années mais qui s'est
probablement accentué pour tout un tas
de raisons alors on évoque les réseaux
sociaux et cetera sans doute
mais je pense que ça pèse sur les prises
de décisions politique mais aussi
d'entreprise d'ailleurs de la même façon
même si les entreprises là-dessus elles
ont pour le coup davantage des cellules
d'anticipation et des de de prospective
donc elles sont probablement
paradoxalement vous savez il y a tout un
tout un argumentaire sur à partir du
moment où c'est du long terme ça peut
pas être le privé ça doit être l'État
mais en réalité souvent les entreprises
gèrent plus à long terme que l'État qui
lui parce qu'il est dirigé par un
personnel politique qui voit l'échéance
de la prochaine élection et cetera a
tendance à raccourcir l'horizon et ça
c'est regrettable j'ai pas l'impression
que la France soit une exception de ce
point de vue et euh c'est probablement
lié à ce que vous disiez c'est-à-dire au
dividendes de la paix qui nous ont mis
un peu dans l'illusion qu'on pouvait
continuer à fonctionner comme ça mais
comme toujours dans tout système le choc
se produit en ce moment la
désorganisation du monde ça va
probablement rétroagir sur le le le le
le
l'écosystème c'est le vieill adage qui
dit que les périodes faciles font des
hommes faibles les périodes difficiles
font des hommes forts c'est ça forcément
forcément les journalistes ils sont
formés comment sur les question question
économique c'est en sortant de l'école
comment ça se passe est-ce que vous
pensez quelle conduite introspective
vous avez sur votre profession
concernant les capacités journalistiques
à faire passer une information de bonne
qualité pour que le public puisse
prendre une décision en son âme et
conscience la formation des journalistes
je suis pas mieux placé j'ai pas de
formation de journaliste moi c'est
peutêre pour ça que vous êtes bon
écoutez ça a été un un handicap au début
de ma carrière de n'avoir pas de
formation économique pas de formation de
journaliste parce que il a fallu que je
je bosse justement que je j'ingère
beaucoup de choses et notamment tout le
fond de SAU quoi pas pas seulement les
classiques mais les grands mécanismes et
cetera j'étais un esprit littéraire moi
j'étais dans Marcel postin enfin et mais
dans Balzac c'est plus proche de
l'économie au fond quand on les Balzac
on on a déjà au fond une bonne culture
économique
eu c'est c'est vrai finalement hein vous
disisez César biroto et sa faillite euh
vous avez à peu près les subprime si ce
n'est que euh ça se termine mal pour
César biroto mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que ça a été un handicap au départ
de ma carrière et puis finalement
maintenant je pense c'est plutôt un
avantage parce que ça me permet de
mettre en lien l'économie avec d'autres
domaines et de faire de la
transversalité qui est une plusvalue
c'est pas la plusvalue ultime mais euh
et autant dans l'expertise la plus
pointue en matière financière je seraai
sûrement pas le meilleur autant pour
pouvoir dire attention là ça ressemble à
octobre 28 et et cetera et il s'est
passé C et ça et en général c'est lié à
telle question géopolitique je peux
faire ça donc je suis probablement pas
le meilleur expert là-dessus pour
répondre à cette question sur la
formation des journalistes je je je je
la seule chose que je peux dire c'est
que je vois des journalistes hein mes
collègues mes amis j'en ai quelques-uns
chez les chez les journalistes bien sûr
que je me suis constitué au fil de de ma
carrière pu Jada c'est un ami oui c'est
quelqu'un pour qui j'ai beaucoup
d'estime qui justement a cette passion
de la découverte des choses qui n'hésite
pas à rentrer dans les sujets compliqués
et notamment en économie moi ça m'a
sidéré parce que comme tous les
journalistes écrit si vous voulez
j'avais le sentiment que l'audiovisuel
au fond c'était forcément un peu plus
léger quoi et vous savez les
journalistes de l'écrit il pensent que
les journalistes deudovisuel sont un peu
légers journalistes de l'audiovisuel
pensent que c'est des crits sont un peu
des bourrins caricature hein mais et
c'est un peu ça nous vous savez ce qu'on
pense des deux ça me fait
peur ne me le dites pas eu mais tout ça
pour dire que en Pujadas j'ai trouvé un
type exigeant compétent
rigoureux et et notamment dans la
pratique de l'interview j'ai appris avec
lui j'ai appris avec lui à serrer
son gars hein partir avec une question
en fait une bonne interview enfin vous
savez ça c'est pas la première question
première question tout le monde l'attend
c'est la relance les relances
c'est-à-dire que en fait ça se passe pas
comme ça non non bah alors sans doute
enfin bon chez nous il y a qu'une seule
question qui compte sur 3 heur
d'interview vous êtes un une espèce
particulière à vous seul mais mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que quand vous
faites une interview à la télé vous avez
peu de temps bon et une bonne interview
c'est celle où vous avez anticipé
exactement comme dans un match de tennis
toutes les positions que vous pouvez
prendre face à la réponse que le type va
vous faire il a trois réponses possibles
vous le voyez en fait ces réponses parce
que quand vous visionnez il faut bosser
quand vous visionnez les interviews de
tel ou tel responsable vous voyez les
les les trois dernières qu'il a donné
mécaniquement il va retomber dans les
même trace donc faut vous les mettre en
tête et vous positionner là où il va
aller pour pouvoir renvoyer la balle et
justement provoquer une surprise quoi
c'est ça une bonne interview j'ai appris
ça avec
davidie les balles ou ou on balance des
enclumesê vous le savez vous saz on est
très bien informé on a des réseau un peu
partout dans le monde oui c'est un
private joke que je vous fais
ditmoi revenons à nos moutons je le sais
en effet comment je le sais en effet
revenons à N mout
France des journalistes qui essayent de
faire comme ils peuvent leur boulot des
politiques qui ont une marge de manœuvre
digne d'une feuille de papier à
cigarette une géopolitique qui est en
train d'être remise en question comme un
divorce qui se passe
mal les jeunes générations
elles vont où elles vont attendre que le
carnage du divorce
s'opère il faut qu'il fasse 100 quel
conseil vous donnez aux jeunes que on
peut euh voir tous les jours en train de
galérer à pas pouvoir se loger des
étudiantes qui sont dans un état de
précarité complètement dingue des des
chaînes de de de gamins en attendant le
Secours populaire pour essayer de
bouffer le soir des logements insalubre
à un prix de dingue des taux d'intérêt
qui qui explosent des gamins qui veulent
plus faire de gamin parce que ça devient
compliqué d'entrevoir l'avenir et une
planète qui part en sucette et des
dirigeants politique qui deviennent de
plus en plus
raid que ce soit avec leur leur
population intérieure ou que ce soit
dans leur discours à l'international on
fait quoi moi j'ai envie de leur dire
alors vous faites quand même une
peinture assez noire de la jeunesse
pourquoi noir parce que il y a il y a
une jeunesse en difficulté il il y en a
une autre elle existe he bien sûr et
elle est importante mais mais il y en a
une autre
qui lutte travaille combien a gamin qui
saute d'Er pas combien il y a
d'étudiants combien il y a d'étudiants
le pourcentage d'étudiants en grande
privation alimentaire non non mais sans
doute comment on fait pour apprendre
quand on n pas assez de calories dans le
sang je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
vous mais euh mais malgré tout vous avez
des jeunes qui arrivent à travailler qui
moi ce qui me frappe avant de répondre à
la question du conseil c'est que par
rapport à ma Gén je suis un baby boomer
tardif moi je suis né enge vous avez
j'ai 62 ans dans 2 jours
euh scorpion ouais
et gros truc chez nous ah bon c'est vrai
et et euh donc conventionnellement les
baby boomers c'est 43 63 je suis juste à
la fin
et cette génération qui est la mienne
ben
elle va partir c'est heureusement et et
et heureusement parce que vous savez ce
que dit la génération juste avant la
vutre he je suis tout à fait d'accord et
heureusement en fait les baby boomers
d'abord ils ont ils ont si vous voulez
quand je je vous parlais au fond là de
de je faisais la rétrospective au début
de notre entretien en filigrane de ces
décennies c'est la montée en puissance
des baby boomers qui est une génération
pour laquelle la liberté individuel
était la clé ils ont tout décidé et fait
à partir de ce critère principal leur
liberté ça avait des des côtés très
positifs hein quand ils avaient 20 ans
68 ils font la révolution pour demander
plus de liberté à partir du moment où
ils entrent sur le marché du travail au
début des années enfin les années 7080
il libéralisent l'économie c'est eux qui
libéralisent l'économie parce que c'est
une génération libérale et puis à mesure
qu'il gagne en responsabilité parce que
dans nos sociétés on arrive au pouvoir
tard on arrive au ben oui les les les
les ceux qui sont s'accroche et à mesure
qu'il gagne en responsabilité justement
le libéralisme gagne aussi
l'abaissement des frontières gagne la
mondialisation progresse ça se superpose
avec la période d'hyperpuissance
américaine qui est l'âge d'or des baby
boomers d'ailleurs l'Amérique c'est
l'idole des baby boomers hein la musique
américaine les voyages en Californie les
valeurs américaines la bouffe américaine
les entrepreneurs la
tech comment la silicone Vallé donc tout
ça c'est l'histoire d'une génération qui
a apporté son lot de choses positives
mais on le voit aujourd'hui aussi son
lot de débois
parce que l'ordre est à reconstruire
aujourd'hui il y a une demande d'ordre
très importante et parce que justement à
force d'avoir contesté toutes les
autorités toutes les limites toutes les
frontières et bien les Baby mers ont
finalement provoqué je me mets dedans on
provoquer une espèce de désordre général
où on sait plus très bien où on en est
la génération qui suit
elle a des valeurs complètement
différentes le collectif a beaucoup plus
d'importance pas forcément le collectif
comme moi je l'entends c'est-à-dire je
sais pas quoi militer dans un parti dans
un syndicat aujourd'hui ces valeursl
elles sont éteintes ce sont des des
étoiles qui sont pis ne disons pas
mortes il est socialiste oui là pour le
coup c'est une étoile éteinte mais mais
mais peut-être que d'autres parties se
reconstruiront je ne sais pas mais c'est
frappant de voir que comment les jeunes
s'investissent dans
l'associatif dans l'humanitaire ma
génération faisit pas ça du tout pas du
tout comment une étoile éteinte je sais
pas un trou noir non après ça tombe en
trou noir peut-être désol c'est fait
exprès pour
couper le fait que l'État cherche à
mettre la main sur quelques fonds de
retraite privée c'est quoi c'est pour
meubler pour récupérer gr la Carco
voulez dire c'est c'est pour gratter un
peu parce qu'on est obbligé de faire les
fonds de tirvoir c'est quoi c'est
scandaleux d'abord
déconn directeur général de car ici que
ça se passe on sentait venir c'est
scandaleux euh pass sympa d'ailleurs je
ne le connais pas et c'est de
l'opportunisme pour boucher des trous
d'un budget qui est à 150 milliards de
déficit donc
euh de la même façon que les transferts
pour les collectivités locales ne se
font plus euh à la hauteur de
l'inflation mais en contrepartie on
permet aux collectivités locales
d'augmenter de 7 % la la en augmentant
les bases locatives d'augmenter la taxe
foncière c'est le même type de système
c'est-à-dire c'est c'est c'est euh euh
des habiller Paul pour hababiller
Jacques ouais c'est des bouts de ficell
un peu pour essayer de boucler un budget
impossible parce que de la France
oui mais c'est comme ça on en est là on
en est là on en est là et alors on peut
pointer la la responsabilité du
gouvernement mais mais pardonnez-moi euh
il me semble que là c'est un problème
bien collectif que là-dessus nous
Français nous sommes d'une immaturité
totale parce que on se tamponne de la
dette bon ok d'accord
collectivement je sais pas si vous avez
vu un sondage récent où on disait quel
est le le l'un des on demandait aux gens
de citer parmi 10 problèmes les deux ou
trois priers importants les deux ou
trois les plus importants la dette
arrivait à 8 % des Français enfin
c'était c'était ridicule mais surtout on
est en demande de dépenses publiqu sans
arrêt quand vous pensez que hier encore
l'État met en place un système de
bonification avec de l'argent parap
public pour réparer les trous dans les
pantalons qui qui qui qui est le miroir
de celui qu'ils avaient mis en place il
y a 18 mois pour réparer les drones mais
attendez on a besoin de l'argent public
pour réparer les drones on rêve ou quoi
quand on pense que vous avez un passe
culture donné au moins de 18 ans 300
balles quel que soit le niveau de revenu
des parents excusez du peu que les
maumes s'en servent pour acheter des
mangas pour je ne sais plus quel
pourcentage c'est bien les mangas oui
sûrement mais c'est pas c'est pas à
faire avec l'argent des impôts vous
voyez c'est les parents qui doivent
payer pour les mangas ou les momes qui
font des des travaux d'été pour le faire
chacun chez soi quoi on n' pas besoin de
collectiviser laachat des mangas ou
alors enfin je sais pas est-ce que on
est en train de s'inspirer du système à
Madagascar où il récupè les briquets par
chargeablees oou ils sont en train de
les rendre rechargeables est-ce qu'on
est en train de se tiermondiser ah ça
c'est un autre angle oui alors il faut
moduler un peu ce que vous dites par le
fait que c'est c'est pas mal hein de
recycler parce qu'on économise de
l'énergie sconn c'est bien ouais non on
économise de l'énergie donc on sera
probablement amené à le faire à refiter
les bagnoles beaucoup plus très bien
mais moi ça me choque pas qu'on recycle
au contraire je pense que c'est
souhaitable maintenant que l'État et
l'argent public alors que on connaît la
situation budgétaire de la France soit
mobilisé à ce point-là pour entrer dans
la vie quotidienne des Français quel que
soit leur niveau de revenu ça me choque
c'est alors la
tirmondisation je la vois plutôt et ça
me préoccupe davantage dans la
détérioration du niveau de service
public là par les hôpitaux mais les
hôpitaux mais pourquoi c'est directement
lié à ce qu'on ce qu'on vient d'évoquer
c'est-à-dire que quand vous regardez sur
longue période le niveau de dépenses
publique ne cesse de progresser en
France avec le niveau d'imposition entre
parenthèses top top là Monsieur Macron
nous dit j'ai baissé les impôts on n'a
jamais payé autant d'impôts en France
jamais de toute l'histoire du pays on
est à 45,4 % du PIB vous prenez 100 100
points de PIB vous en avez 46,4 qui
partent à l'état ou à ces satellites
jamais on a connu ça jamais on a connu
un niveau de dépenses publique aussi
élevé et pourtant les hôpitaux et les
services publics faiblissent qu'est-ce
qui se passe alors bon il y a une
composante démographique qu'on est plus
vieux les traitements coûtent plus cher
d'accord c'est sûr mais il y a aussi un
une autre dimension sur laquelle on
n'insiste jamais et qui me paraît
essentielle c'est que la redistribution
dans les passcultures dans les bonus
réparation de trous à vos chaussures
dévore l'argent public au détriment des
services publics plus ou moins que
l'évasion
fiscale l'évasion fiscale elle est
difficile à quantifier par définition se
fait beaucoup quand même il y en a qui
sont oui mais vous savez que la France
est quand même un des pays qui collecte
le mieux l'impôt alors pas sur tous les
facteurs imposables sur les
individus non c'est vrai on a un taux de
collègue qui est assez bon sauf chez les
milliardaires alors il y a effectivement
des différences en fonction des niveaux
de revenus avec des proportions d'impôts
qui ne sont pas du tout les mêmes
suivant les tranches de revenus dans
lesquelles vous vous opérez c'est
certains
mais réglons si l'on peut la question de
évasion
fiscale peine de mort ça ça
solutionne il y a d'autres solutions je
crois parce l'évasion fiscale qui me
pourrit mes mes services
publics je voudrais pas me
nord-coréaniser mais ça mériterait quand
même des peines de prison
ferme laissons juste de côté l'évasion
fiscale à un moment je reviens sur il y
a quand même cette problè ce problème de
redistribution réglée et puis la
suradministration hein une couche de
couche de surcouche euh
c'est combien de fonctionnaires à
combien de fonctionnaires à la mairie de
Paris combien de
fonctionnaires on est à plusieurs
dizaines de milliers à la maie de Paris
c'est quoi c'est un réservoir de vote ça
c'est quoi je pense c'est la culture
française c'est l'idée que dès qu'il y a
un problème c'est l'État qui est le plus
apte à le régler j'ai fait ma chronique
ce matin sur ce fameux barem sur ce
fameux bonus de réparation des
vêtements donc c'est de l'argent qui est
collecté sur la vente de tous les les
vêtements
neufs il y a
104 vêtements différents qui ont été
identifiés par l'administration chacun a
un taux de taxe différent qu'est-ce que
vous entendez par 104 parce que moi je
connais que pyjama pour les moins de 14
ans pyjama pour les plus de 14 ans
femmes euh costume de déguisement
euh semel semel en gomme enfin chaussur
avec semel à gomme chaussures avec semel
en cuir c'est du délire par ailleurs
vous l'argent collecté là va être
utilisé non seulement pour financer les
bonus mais pour donner des primes aux
entreprises méritantes qui vont recycler
des matériaux mais elles ne toucheront
la prime que si les produits qu'elle
recycent ont été prélevés à moins de
1500 km de l'endroit où elle retraite
sauf si on peut pas mesurer cette
distance dans ce cas-là nous dit le
décret du 22 novembre 2022 on considère
le baricentre de la
France le bariccentre de la France et
les gars donneent la Latitude et la
Longitude on creuse non je je peux pas
vous dire
j'ai donné à l'antenne ce matin la
latitude avec les minutes et les degrés
parce que c'est dans le décret du du
Journal Officiel du 22 novembre 2022
c'est pour vous dire que qui est-ce qui
a écrit le décret mais je ne sais pas
c'est effectivement la question
intéressante quel est l'esprit malade
qui a écrit ce décret pas dire esprit
malade c'est pas gentil oui mais
franchement voyez c'est sorti
spontanément mais tout ça pour dire que
bon l'évasion fiscale c'est un sujet
mais il y a aussi un sujet d'efficacité
et de de de disons de bonne allocation
des ressources en parlant d'allocation
des ressources bon l'évasion fiscale on
va y revenir quand on voit une une
ubérisation des services publics du
conseil quand on voit des milliards et
des milliards payés en institut de
conseil c'est normal c'est pas normal
c'est parce que notre état s'est empaté
avec 25000 couches de gars qui servent
plus à rien qui ne comprennent
strictement rien je crois que qui ne
sont pas agiles en temps de mauvais
temps vous avez fait du bateau c'est ça
non j'en ai fait je suis pas un expert
mais j'en ai fait qu qu type de bateau
quelle position sur le bateau oh c'était
c'était c'est des petits bateaux c'était
des 470 je sais pas si ça existe encore
c'est des petits dériveurs de plaisance
façon laser non c'est un peu plus grand
que le laser et ça fait 4 M70
donc quand on change de bord il faut
faut se bouger ah il faut se bouger sin
sinon on se fait à sommet oui ou donc là
là on a des changements de bord à
effectuer on est en N trouble on une
surreprésentation de la hiérarchie ou
des couches de strat de fonctionnaires
de pas fonctionnaires des organismes qui
règlent la même chose mais ils sont
différents pas au bon endroit au même
endroit avec des crédits différents des
budgets différents la région pas la
région je reviens toujours à la même
question imaginez-vous vous êtes sur
votre petit laser en face de
Belly B c'est trop cher on va dire un
peu plus bas qu'
Bron ça se lève gros
là la la géopolitique il y a Poutine qui
nous fait des petites démonstrations que
le nucléaire il est déjà bien pointu et
que faudra pas le trop fatiguer les
Iraniens les démons se
réveillent le le la pénombre émerge et
les démons émergent notre administration
qui nous pont des euh crédit je sais pas
comment vous avez appeler ça é éch
participation sur le pyjama de 14 ans
les smell enom pas enom le barissante de
pas
barissante vous avez envie de leur dire
quoi vous avez envie de leur dire vous
allez me trouver le nom de monsieur qui
a passé x semaines à pondre ça et vous
allez poser la question la diluion de la
responsabilité quand il y a gros
temps le capitaine qui fait un peu
n'importe quoi avec la barre il a une
mutinerie au bout de 2
minutes là on fait quoi va y avoir une
mutinerie pas une mutinerie est-ce que
le mamouth va crever dans sa graisse je
pense qu'il y aura pas de mutinerie que
c'est un système trop verrouillé
complexe et que c'est d'ailleurs
l'explication de l'utilisation des
cabinets de conseil hein c'est alors
c'est que finalement le le truc est
devenu tellement compliqué queil y a
plus personne à l'intérieur qui permet
ENF qui a la la la capacité de
comprendre l'ensemble et de trouver les
points d'ancrage pour prendre une
décision et et actionner les levier quoi
et et et donc du coup on a besoin d'un
regard extérieur parce qu'on a plus les
compétences en interne la haute fonction
publique c'est quand même déqualifié
beaucoup par rapport à il y a 30 4 faut
faut faut songer quand même que les les
grands programmes industriels de la
France qui avaient été conçus pour
partie d'ailleurs par la la haute
fonction publique c'était le fruit de
de une quinzaine d'esprits he qui était
les conseillers de Pompidou et cetera
Bernard Ebert Ebert
évidemment et et que on a plus ça quoi
ils sont ils sont plus au cœur de la
machine publique malheureusement ces
gensl ils ils sont mauvais ou ils sont
pas
patriotes peut-être les
deux je pense que ils sont dans un
système qui est décourageant parce qu'il
est trop lourd complexe et que
finalement justement comme vous le
disiez la responsabilité est diluée que
l'idée même de faire bouger quelque
chose je me souviens je sais pas si vous
souvenez Thierry Mandon qui a été de la
simplification
administrative et je l'ai vu après son
départ mais il était proche de la la
dépression c'est-à-dire que le type
était de bonne foi c'est quelqu'un qui
est voilà qui est tout à fait outillé
pour pouvoir traiter des problème
complexes mais voilà il avait bien
conscience que finalement son
œuvre ne parviendrait pas à naître quoi
parce que c'est trop compliqué il y a
trop de réticence les couches se se se
se superpose et du coup on sait plus
très bien par quel bout prendre le truc
c'est pour ça qu'il y aura pas de
mutinerie je pense chacun est dans son
son alvéole et que du coup bah le voilà
est occupé à sa tâche immédiate mais que
il y a plus personne pour prendre le
plan global là-dessus d'ailleurs je
trouve que c'est c'est l'un des points
sur lequel le quinquen d'Emmanuel Macron
et
vide la réforme de l'État attention je
vais me faire l'avocat du diable bon ben
je vous écoute non non je vous
laissminer c'est que lui au
fonctionnaire inspecteur des finances
qui connaît au mieux la machine il ne il
ne l'a pas prise à bras le corp et au au
contraire il considère que c'est pas un
sujet
et c'est ce qui nous donne ce délire de
règlement j'ai
fait une observation là la dernière
année de session parlementaire je crois
qu'il y avait 85 jours de session on a
voter 69 lois 69 lois pour 85 jours ça
veut dire un jour et demi par
loi mais comment est-ce qu'on peut
travailler sérieusement là-dessus c'est
pas possible vous pouvez pas
raisonnablement envisager l'examen d'une
loi aussi rapidement alors derrière vous
avez des armées de fonctionnaires mais
qui finissent par travailler un peu
en en autonomie et et et de fait les
normes s'additionnent se superposent se
contredisent et et et on ne sait plus
très bien où on est du coup toute
décision est annoncée avec
force trompette voilà on fait la prime
renve qui va vous permettre de rénover
votre maison et de toucher des
subventions et c'est simplifié mais
quand on regarde dedans on se plonge
là-dedans c'est d'une complexité inouï
quoi et ça n'est pas opérationnel
derrière ça fait augmenter les prix
parce qu'ils savent qu'il on évidemment
évidemment quand vous subventionnez
quelque chose mécaniquement le type qui
fournit le service en question il se dit
bon allez je fais un peu de gratte hein
ça c'est c'est humain donc ça pour le
coup vous voyez autant je suis très
confiant sur la génération qui vient je
pense que votre retraite j'espère alors
j'ai pas envie de la prendre tout de
suite hein
mais mais mais non je pense qu'ils ont
des des des des capacité justement dans
l'organisation du collectif que ma
génération n'avait pas et si vous deviez
mettre un titre à cette volonté vous
metteriez quoi comme titre la volonté de
la volonté des jeunes c'est ça le titre
oui c'est ben c'est c'est le le vraiment
le sens du collectif et le le fait de se
penser comme un élément dans un tout
quoi et si vous étiez amené à penser
contre vous-même sur ce ce bout de
phrase c'est-à-dire de considérer que
cette jeunesse ne n'en valait pas la
peine non si je vous dis quand les
jeunes se vengeront ah oui c'est
possible non c'est possible quand je dis
j'ai confiance je
je est-ce qu'on hypothèque pas trop le
futur de notre alors j'ai écrit un
bouquin là-dessus qui s'appelait tant
pis nos enfants Pons et c'était ça
c'était la guerre des
générations effectivement
alors c'est vrai que les baby boomers je
reprends une expression de mon maître
Marc de ctivau il disait c'est une
génération qui a escroqué ses parents et
ses enfants ses parents parce que elle a
payé son patrimoine immobilier en
monnaie de singe avec l'inflation hein
qui a permis de réduire le poids de la
dette donc elle a escroqué euh ce
d'avant et ce d'après parce que elle
s'est endetté comme une brute avec la
dette publique en faisant financer par
la puissan publique des niveaux de santé
et de retraite qui ne sont pas
soutenables donc euh c'est vrai ça c'est
vrai cette génération des baby boomers à
laquelle j'appartiens je suis un baby
boomer de fin de ligne mais de fait je
le suis est une génération trop pardon
ça se voit pas trop pas mais de de fait
c'est une cheveux blanc parce que j'ai
pas de cheveux oui c'est ça Cuse du
volcan c'est ça oui c'est
ça mais de fait c'est une génération qui
a d'abord pensé à elle donc on ne peut
pas exclure la vengeance mais en avant
même la vengeance il faut que les gars
prennent le
pouvoir parce que les baby boomers en
plus les gars ils ont Bénéfic des
progrès de santé qui leur font être en
pleine santé à 70 ans donc à 70 ans ils
disent mais attends moi je veux
resterin homme politique dirigeant
journaliste il faut se mettre dedans
après tout donc alors que nos
prédécesseurs c'était pas le cas il y a
30 ou 40 ans 70 ans on n'était pas dans
le même état physique donc c'est c'est
ils ont bénéficié de l'allongement de la
durée de la vie en bonne santé de façon
incroyable c'est probablement la
génération qui en a bénéficié le plus
plus quand on voit à l'heure actuelle
nos nos politiques déployer un bouclier
tarifaire quand on voit des prix
pratiquement encadrés des prix
bloqués quand on voit l'encadrement des
loyers quel reg regard vous portez sur
c'est une question intéressante parce
que j'observe comme vous que ça se
multiplie
hein et en général quand on bloque un
prix c'est comme sur la clé de
barbebleleue vous frottez d'un côté ça
réapparaît derrière qu'est-ce qui se
passe quand on bloque un prix on joue
sur les quantités j'observez ça il y a
pas longtemps vous savez on a bloqué
aussi on a tarifé les taxis pour aller
de Paris à Orly 35 € pour 50 balles pour
aller à Charles Gou c'est ça à peu près
je ne sais plus quel est le prix pour
j'ai en tête le prix de de d'or mais
pour pour Rossi je pense que c'est cet
ordre là les taxis considèrent que c'est
pas
assez donc on a bloqué un prix qu'est-ce
qui se passe ils vont plus à Orley et
maintenant Orley vous attendez beaucoup
plus longtemps un taxi c'est les
quantités qui qui ont été ajusté quoi et
et on observe ça aussi sur les loyers
hein ça a été bloqué regardez dans Paris
de temps en temps vous voyez des fils de
200 personnes pour un appartement dit
d'ailleurs généralement alors pour le
coup j'ai pas été voir mais ce que je
veux dire c'est d'aller visiter un
appartement à 800 balles par mois à
Paris avec les toilettes sur le palier
ou le bloc douche à l'intérieur dans une
pièce sûr pour 800 balles c'est c'est
une chambre maintenant c'est et
euh donc si vous voulez quand les les
propriétaires considèrent que justement
les loyers bloqués il payent trop
d'impôts fonciers en plus avec les
nécessités de rénovation énergétique
vous savez la sortie des logements
classés l'stabilité du système
économiqueabilité incessante ils disent
bon bah finalement
euh ça m'intéresse plus de louer je sais
pas quoi je je le vends de fait ça
restraint l'offre l'offre de de de de
location privée je je voyais des
statistiques qui viennent d'un sondage
de la FNAIM qui est la Fédération des
des agences immobilières euh 40 % en
moins de d'appartements à louer par
rapport à l'année dernière dans des
villes comme Paris ou Rennes c'est
considérable mais mais pourquoi parce
que l'individu propriétaire petit
propriétaire d'ailleurs c'est pas
forcément le Milie le millionnaire ou à
for le milliardaire se dit bah
franchement ça vaut pas le coup
c'est-à-dire que le blocage des prix est
une est un
expédient temporaire qui généralement
déplace le problème et crée des pénuries
vous savez comme moi que pendant la
Révolution française on avait bloqué le
prix du pain qui était un élément
stratégique et à certains moment on l'a
bloqué en dessous du prix de la farine
façon Égypte de 2010 oui mais alors si
la farine est plus chère que le pain
vous avez besoin de la farine vous avez
besoin d'eau et puis vous de la chaleur
et il faut du travail comment être
motivé pour faire du pain puisque vous
êtes sûr de perdre de l'argent avec
l'opération et qu'en plus vous y aurez
passé 3h vous serez levé à 2h du matin
ben voilà tout est là tout est là il
faut quand même
que vous savez c'est la fameuse phrase
d'Adam Smith il faut pas attendre de la
bienveillance du boucher du boulanger
qu'il pourvoie à nos repas je cite de
mémoire mais de son intérêt hein c'est
que et si vous contrariez son intérêt
bah mécaniquement vous faites que le
boulanger il va plutôt s'allonger dans
l'air
quoi est-ce que vous avez suivi le fait
que maintenant l'État français souscrit
de la dette mais à tout variable oui
c'est en fait ça a été ça a été initié
il y a quelques années euh et ce sont
des obligations indexées sur l'inflation
qui de fait reviennent à des taux
variable he et ça explique d'ailleurs
pour cette année l'essentiel de
l'augmentation du coût de la dette parce
que on provisionne les charges
supplémentaires qui sont liées à ça
c'est je crois que ça représente une
dizaine ou une douzaine de pourcent du
stock de dett français donc c'est pas
négligeable ça a été fait à un moment où
l'inflation était à zéro hein ù faible
en tout cas et où ça permettait d'avoir
un taux d'intérêt plus faible que de
s'endetter à taux fixe le coût est
évidemment considérable aujourd'hui ça
me fait penser à l'emprunt d'excès sur
l'or d'un ministre des
Finances de de nager qui s'appelait
Valérie jiscard desestin qui a coûté aux
finances publiques extrêmement cher ça
me fait penser aux emprunts des
collectivités territoriales souscrit
avant la crise de 2008 à taux variable
oui oui non il y il y a toujours des des
erreurs de prévision au fond le taux
fixe en économie comme dans la vie
réelle le sujet central c'est le partage
du
risque et tout le monde se bat pour
repousser le risque sur l'autre quoi en
repoussant les contraintes et le taux
variable ben l'emprunteur il assume
l'intégralité du risque un taux fixe
vous savez pas trop ça peut enfin sêter
quand les taux étaient faibles sanster à
tau fixe c'était plutôt une bonne idée
et les Français qui l'ont fait sans
faéli citron je pense ceux qui ont
emprunté à 1 ou à 2 % dans les années
récentes est-ce qu'on parle des bricks
oui est-ce qu'on parle de il y a plus en
plus de pays qui veulent rejoindre les
bricks oui est-ce qu'on parle que la
dédollarisation du monde oui la la la
sousévaluation du Yan les
paniers de monnaie basé bqué sur des
matières premières des petites choses
comme ça les
bricks c'est là aussi je pense il faut
réélargir la focale en fait quand je
vous parlais Ukraine Ukraine Gaza
Ukraine Israël
finalement l'une des lignes de fracture
du monde c'est the West and the rest
l'Occident contre le reste du monde ce
West and the rest c'est une expression
de l'Ouest et le rest oui c'est ça de
Neil Ferguson vous savez cet historien
écossais
euh qui qui a travaillé beaucoup sur le
20e siècle et même sur les périodes
avant historien de la bonnet euh qui a
raconté la naissance de la monnaie et
euh donc les bricks là-dedans euh c'est
les challengers hein c'est ceux qui
justement souvenez-vous quand cette
expression a été inventée c'était en
2001 je crois c'est Jim o'il un des
responsables de Goldman sax aux
États-Unis et qui disait voilà ce groupe
de pays Brésil Russie Inde Chine et
Afrique du Sud va devenir euh une espèce
de banlieu sympathique dans laquelle on
pourra vendre nos produits en gros hein
euh et puis et puis et puis ils ont
grandi hein ils se sont affirmés en 2008
on crée le G20 avec l'idée de les
associer à la gouvernance mondiale on
leur donne un collier avec de verutterie
hein en leur disant les amis euh voilà
ça vous suffira mais en réalité l'ordre
du monde ne change pas et puis puis le
temp passe et et aujourd'hui la la Chine
est devenue un peu le challenger de de
des États-Unis avec l'idée qu'elle veut
reprendre sa place de première économie
mondiale et elle devient le chef des
bricks je fais juste une petite
parenthèse vous savez qu'il y a un
économist s'appelle angugus Madison
suédois comme son nom l'indique qui est
mort il y a une quinzaine d'années il a
passé sa vie à reconstituer le PIB de
tous les pays depuis l'an 1000 il
incluait le la drogue la prostitution
les armes de alors je ne sais pas parce
que là là récemment c'est ce qu'on
essaie de faire là oui je je honnêtement
je ne sais pas toute façon c'était avec
des sources qui étaient euh vous savez
assez littéraire si s'est appuyé sur des
textes sur des rapports des contrats
commerciaux et cetera mais il montre
très bien que de l'an 1000 à l'an 1840
en gros la Chine c'est 20 à 30 % du PIB
mondial à partir de 1840 1842 c'est le
traité de Nankin hein l'opium bien sûr
et et la Chine commence ce qu'elle
appelle elle maintenant le siècle de
l'humiliation la grande dégringolad les
famines les guerres mot pour ça le
siècle le sècle le siècle de la ah oui
oui oui c'est c'est c'est c'est vraiment
une expression qu'on entend souvent chez
les Chinois parce que il y a le
sentiment que l'Occident leur a pris
leur place quoi on arrive en
49 il y a une différence entre prendre
la place et permettez-moi
l'expression de vous oui parce
que le l'opium bien sûr bien sûr c'est
c'est c'était pas on se battait à la loy
c'est de la prédation tout à fait c'est
de la prédation non non vous avez raison
de faire la nuance sont fairplay hein
oui je pense
qu'ilou mis trop fort mais donc en fait
le le le PIB chinois passe de 2 % à 4 et
demi quand Mao prend le pouvoir quand en
proportion de PIB mondial puis ça bouge
pas jusqu'au lancement des réformes de T
pig en 79 on reste entre 4 et 5 et
depuis on est remonté à plus de 20 quoi
mais ils veulent aller au-delà et et les
bricks sont il veent aller au-delà ou
ils veulent se venger je pense que ils
veulent retrouver leur place de leader
mondial et ne plus subir un ordre imposé
par les autres c'est c'est et en fait
tous les bricks sont dans cet état là
l'Inde dit la même chose dit les amis
mais attendez 1 MLI 4 c'est qui c'est
nous et de surqui elle est devenue
l'alternative à la Chine pour la
fabrication de produits électroniques
Apple maintenant fait fabriquer ses
produits là-bas
donc l'Inde dit bon 9 % de
croissance je suis pas sûr d'ailleurs
qu'il connaissent un destin comparable à
celui de la Chine parce que au moins en
Chine l'avantage du communisme avait été
d'éradiquer le féodalisme et et de
construire des hôpitaux et des écoles
pour tout le monde et partout ça change
la donne he en Inde c'est pas tout à
fait ça on encore on a visité un hôpital
à Varanassi c'était très spécial où ça
pardon à Varanassi Benares de votre oui
c'est ça bien sûr oui bien sûr en Chine
moi j'ai vécu en Chine dans les années
80 et et notamment dans une université
médicale l'université médicale numéro 2
qui avait été l'université Aurore fondée
par les jésuites français au début du
20e siècle mais donc j'avais un des
hôpitaux les plus prestigieux il y avait
des salles enent terbattu mais on vous
soignait hein et et on vous soignait
pour vraiment trois F comme on disait à
l'époque hein le F chinois j'avais
appris un petit peu en fait c'était ma
troème langue au bac donc j'ai pris mon
premier cours de chinois le jour de la
mort de maetou en septembre 76 et j'en
ai fait oui bien sûr oui oui c'était
juste après ce tremblement de terre
incroyable qui a fait des centaines de
milliers de victimes en Chine et puis
j'ai eu l'occasion de partir en Chine
après donc je l'ai entretenu un peu
là-bas mais honnêtement enfin quand je
suis sur place ça me revient un peu mais
jeai jamais eu une pratique les chinois
ils ont essayé de vous tamponner depuis
ou pas de tamponner c'est-à-dire de vous
approcher de vous sussurer à l'oreille
ce qu'il faudrait dire de bien sur la
Chine jamais jamais jamais jamais je
suis très critique sur la Chine
d'ailleurs c'est un pays que j'aime bien
euh mais euh mais je pense que il faut
se protéger que vous aimez bien ou c'est
le pays ou les deux les deux vraiment je
pense que il ressemble beaucoup au
français c'est des individualistes
forcenés c'est le bordel partout c'est
d'abord la famille c'est l'attrait pour
euh les plaisirs de la table euh c'est
une culture qui est assez proche de
contrairement au japonais qui sont des
communistes nés hein où le groupe
prévaut sur l'individu de façon
structurel les Chinois c'est moi d'abord
comme nous hein
et j'ai j'ai j'ai eu vraiment des très
bons amis que j'ai malheureusement perdu
de vue mais et le pays est somptueux
c'est magnifique je peux pas dire de
banalité là-dessus
mais n'empêche que il faut se protéger
des Chinois parce que et je reviens au
bricks cette partition du
monde finalement pour l'Europe elle pose
quand même un problème ça rejoint la
question que vous posez tout à l'heure
c'est est-ce que on essaie de construire
un bloc à nous qu'on est oxyant deux en
quelque sorte distinct des États-Unis ça
va pas marcher je pense que ça ne va pas
marcher et que le destin logique et que
les États-Unis restent le chef de
l'Occident et que
on voit bien que certains pays d'Europe
de l'Est d'ailleurs comme la Pologne
considèrent que en dehors du parapluie
américain en terme de défense il y a pas
de solution la
France crie très fort mais pour
construire une défense européenne mais
mais elle n'a pas les moyens de de sa
politique d'autant que les dissensions
avec l'Allemagne sont de plus en plus
fortes sur ce sujet donc il est à
craindre que nous soyons nous Ress un
satellite un satellite occidental
avec l'Amérique à sa
tête ça ça c'est comme ça depuis un bon
siècle
euh alors après la question c'est parmi
les bricks évidemment c'est la Chine qui
prend le leadership la Chine peut-elle
devenir le maître du monde à la place
des États-Unis je ne le crois pas je ne
pense pas pour plusieurs raisons il la
Belgique d'abord il y a pardon il y aura
la Belgique avant ou là je doute un peu
peut-être sur le long terme mais mais
non il y a d'abord des raisons
démographiques qui fait que la Chine va
devenir un gigantesque épad dans 30 ans
hein il y a des raisons le Japon dans 5
ans donc ça va oui le Japon l' déjà même
quasiment il y a des raisons aussi je
pense proprement économique si on
revient au début de notre conversation
avec l'accumulation de la dette qui va
se révéler un jour que va donner la
croissance en Chine je ne sais pas et
puis il y a une autre raison c'est que
la Chine ne fait pas envie un maître du
monde doit faire
rêver l'Amérique pour les immigrés du
monde entier au 19e siècle au début du
20e siècle vous étiez persécuté pour des
raisons de religion de d'orientation
politique ou sexuelle quelle qu'on soit
la raison c'était l'Amérique parce que
vous étiez sûr qu'il y avait la garantie
des droits de propriété donc ce que vous
alliez construire pour vous ça resterait
à vous ou à vos enfants que c'était un
pays libre et la Chine n'a pas ça
d'ailleurs j'observe que les riches
Chinois ont tous un passeport américain
par sécurité les riches américains ils
ont pas de passeport chinois parce que
un passeport chinois ça servirait pas à
grand-chose si ce n'est à pouvoir aller
en vacances un peu plus souvent mais et
et et c'est j'ai eu aussi cette vraiment
ce flash au moment de la mort
d'Élisabeth II c'était incroyable cette
vieille dame paix à son âme paix à son
âme avec ses chapeaux et cetera rose bon
cette classe cette classe mais qui au
fond a maintenu l'idée que il fallait
préserver une certaine forme de de de de
de
stabilité c'est c'est le maintien de la
royauté au travers de cette époque
troublée qu'elle a connu je suis là pour
vous dire que sur le fondamental rien ne
change bon on peut être contreou pour
c'est pas mon sujet moi ça m'a frappé
elle est morte le monde entier 4
milliards de personnes regardent
l'entérement 4 milliards
euh c'est la survivance de
l'extraordinaire prévalence qu'avait
l'Empire britannique au 19e siècle
un/art des terres émergées hein le plus
grand empire construit par par l'homme
quand sitingping va mourir il y aura pas
4 milliards de gens devant la télé pour
regarder le catafalque et on se dira
bon desbas quoi hein et
ou pas peut-être pas en Chine je ne sais
pas
mais en tout cas ce que je veux dire
c'est que pour être maître du monde
qu'on aura après non vous avez raison
c'est vrai c'est c'est c'est une
remarque judicieuse c'est ça vaut aussi
pour Poutine d'ailleurs ça vaut aussi
pour Françis
Hollande
mais non c'est que
finalement le maître du monde doit avoir
des attributs de séduction
que la Chine n'a pas de sur croix au
plan militaire
j'observe que la Chine n'a jamais
combattu à l'étranger sauf une fois
récemment où elle s'est pris une raclé
contre les Vietnamiens vietnamiens
peuple de combattant qui s'est quand
même farci les Américains les Français
auparavant et les Chinois après donc bon
il y aura un blocus sur il y aura une
crise à Taiwan c'est sûr ça il y a aucun
doute dessus aucun parce que l'enjeu est
trop important pour la Chine une crise
sous quelle forme une crise crise
militaiseita une crise militaire il y a
militaire et militaire oui il y a il y a
blocus je te fais crever sur ton île et
il y a je viens te mettre un peu je
pense que la première étape ça sera ça
ça sera le blocus d'ailleurs vous savez
les les militaires américains les les
géostratèges Américains disent c'est
2027 parce que cting ping est encore là
c'est la fin de son 3è mandat et parce
que les capacités maritimes auront ont
atteint un tel niveau queon pourra
justement faire un blocus un blocus
auquel l'Î pourra difficilement résister
alors évidemment mais l'enjeu est
considérable pour vous savez j'ai
rencontré une fois Kissinger les
répercussions sur les semic-onducteur à
l'échelle mondiale ça va être une
catastrophe mais bon oui alors on est en
train de s'équiper pour que ça le soit
moins vous avez vu qu' il y a énormément
de d'usines qui se construisent aux
États-Unis on s'équipe on fait des
sauvegardes d'entreprises aux États-Unis
oui Europe
avec des capacités de production pour
fournir que l'industrie militaire oui au
moins au début mais je pense ça va
s'étendre puis vous avez quand même ASML
la l'entreprise néerlandaise qui
fabrique les les machines pour la
gravure hein je veux dire on on a un
capital quand même technologique qui
n'est pas exploité autant qu'il aurait
dû he ça c'est certain on a été d'une
négligence incroyable jusqu'à il y a 2
ou 3 ans en laissant se constituer dans
une zone risquée le centre de production
mondiale sur ses composants STR c'est la
négligence ou de la corruption je pense
que c'est de la négligence je pense vous
savez souvent rasoir
d'cam souvent quand
on on s'interroge sur le complot
euh rasoir de Cam ça paye tout de suite
pardon l'explication de la plus simple
est souvent la meilleure ils sont juste
très pané et médiocre ils ont pas
anticipé on se retrouve avec tous les
ufs dans le même panier il y a même pas
de complot à voir qu'il y a un grand
remplacement de bidule un grand ordre
mondial c'est juste des crétins oui je
le je le dirai pas avec vos mots mais je
suis d'accord avec vous c'est-à-dire que
entre le complot et le conformisme le
manque d'imagination le manque
d'attention au monde c'est bien sûr la
deuxième raison qui prévaut ça c'est sûr
euh on va pas avoir le temps de faire
tous les sujets que j'avais préparé avec
vous c'est bien dommage il va falloir
revenir euh bah avec plaisir quelle
heure est-il il est pas très tard ça
fait que 2h20 qu'on est en direct c'est
pas vrai si juste un truc libérez-moi
pas trop tard parce que j'ai ma
chronique à faire pour demain ah vous
avez vos devoirs vous êes pour vos
devoir c'est quoi votre chronique pour
demain et bien écoutez ça va être sur
l'Irlande et le Portugal qui constittu
des fonds souverains de victimes de la
crise de l'euro incroyable qui constitue
des fonds souverains pour investir dans
les projets stratégiques pour demain et
dans les les les des fonds climatiques
enfin pour l'environnement deux pays qui
sont en en excédent budgétaire quoi
c'est incroyable comme quoi le la la
mélace budgétaire dans laquelle on est
elle n'est pas irrémédiable il suffit
quand même d'avoir des équipes qui sont
déterminées pour traiter le problème et
on peut complètement inverser la
situation c'est pas le cas avec nous les
49 3 répétitions c'est que ils veulent
passer en force ils sont intimement
persuadé de
leur leur justesse d'esprit on ne touche
pas à la dépense publique donc
voilà qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je
vous dise allea Jaa
est estce est-ce que vous avez un sujet
que vous souhaiteriez aborder avec nous
qu'on a pas traité avant la prochaine
fois qu'on avant notre prochaine
interview la caisse des retraite on a
traité c'est un braquage un raquette un
rançonnage un briolage ou un brigandage
les prélèvements pégulatoire qu'on a pas
trop testé la croissance qui ralentisse
on en a parlé le protectionnisme on en a
parlé tous des règles on en a parlé les
aides de Noël non c'est quoi les aides
de Noël bah là ils vont filer entre 120
balles et 200 balles pour les plus
pauvres oui une petite subvention
déguisée pour les fêtes de Noël pour
éviter que les commerçants calanent ou
que les fournisseurs de jou Calanche oui
ça a toujours ce double objectif mais
bon mais c'est absolument génial c'est
tenez les les les pauvres l'état donc
moi mais en fait c'est c'est ce qui est
frappant c'est ça c'est que aujourd'hui
quand vous prenez le revenu des
Français il y a un bon tiers qui vient
de la redistribution alors ça s'explique
aussi par le fait que la part des
retraité plus importante mais mais c'est
la prime d'activité qui complète les les
SMIC et qui c'est incroyable j'ai fait
j'ai découvert ça il y a pas longtemps
j'ai fait une chronique là-dessus donc
vous vous gagnez le SMIC aujourd'hui
votre employeur veut vous augmenter de
100 € parce que vous êtes un type qui
considère comme compétent il doit payer
si vous siil veut que vous ayez vraiment
100 € dans la poche il il doit payer 44
0 € de plus parce que les charges
sociales augmentent considérablement
vous sortez du seuil d'exonération et du
coup vous payez en tant qu'employeur
beaucoup plus de charge sociale sur tout
le salaire pas seulement sur
l'augmentation et parce que la prime
d'activité diminue c'est-à-dire que
l'État qui complète les ressources de
votre salarié complète moins parce qu'il
considère qu'il gagne plus vous imaginez
comme quoi une bonne intention compléter
les revenus des salariés auos SMIC finit
par se traduire par un taux de
prélèvement de 400 % c'est-à-dire que le
prélèvement au bas de l'échelle de
revenus est plus important qu'au haut de
l'échelle des revenus on est dans un
système qui de ce point de vue marche
sur la
tête un commentaire de la communauté
lutter contre l'évasion fiscale avec
moins de fonctionnairees pour le faire
mais bien sûr c'est vrai que euh on on
en reparlera des l'évasion trois
bouquins conseillés à notre communauté
alors vous avez pas le droit de
conseiller les votes tout de
suite ah c'était quoi votre sujet par
non mais c'était vous pour le coup je
suis reparti sur le sur le la
redistribution donc
euh non je je voulais juste vous dire
oui
que enfin c'est ma thèse au fond
mais dans cette crise de transition on
en voit on en a vu les prolagomèes
douloureux avec la crise financière et
puis le le détricotage progressif
politique géopolitique j'y reviens pas
on est probablement dans la phase
explication la plus douloureuse qui se
traduit toujours par des conflits mais
si on si on se fit à l'histoire qu'on
observe justement les crises qui
ressemblaient un peu au nôtres derrière
en général l'élite se renouvelle c'est
un paramètre clé il n'y a pas de
solution de crise sans changement des
élites c'est pas possible c'est pour ça
que le renouvellement des générations
est capital parce que les générations
c'est assez curieux mais une génération
c'est un ensemble de personnes ils ont
des valeurs communes qui ne sont pas les
mêmes que celles de leur père chaque
génération se définit un peu contre
celle qui l'a précédé la génération
libérale la mienne elle s'est défini
contre celle qui nous a précédé qui
était dominée par les désastres de la
guerre et elle voulait de la liberté
parce que justement elle ne voulait pas
la vie de ses pères mais celle qui nous
suit au contraire elle va vouloir je
pense de l'ordre et et et davantage de
collectif et c'est ça qui est le moteur
l'aiguillon du changement j'en reviens à
l'idée que derrière cette crise
il est tout à fait possible qu'on
connaisse une période beaucoup plus
paisible et que la croissance revienne
modulau la question climatique ça
suppose évidemment qu'elle soit sinon
réglée du moins apaisée avec la
réorganisation de l'économie recyclage
pourquoi pas et des innovations qui nous
permettraient de passer entre les
gouttes je ne sais pas qui gagnera dans
la course de vitesse entre le changement
climatique et l'innovation humaine
personne ne peut le dire avec certitude
mais il faut souvenir que si je puis
dire en 1350
quand les gars ont eu l'épidémie de
peste et que ça a tué la moitié des
Européens les de tiers des Italiens bon
ils ont dû être encore plus flippés que
nous le sommes quoi et finalement ceux
qui ont survécu ils étaient immunisés
ils ont reconstruit et c'est
reparti c'est ce que je nous souhaite
une épidémie de peste à l'heure actuelle
je sais pas comment on fait pour
entretenir notre système nucléaire
comment rag peut
fonctionner c'est peut-être pas les
mêmes les mêmes choses non c'était une
métaphore oui merci des fois je suis un
peu primitif primaire trois bouquins
nous conseiller alors euh je note je
note pendant que vous réfléchissez je
note cette petite touche à chaque fois
de positif parce qu'il faut quand même
rester positif et qu'il faut y croire
c'est pas c'est pas que je me bat les
flansc pour ou je bat les buissons pour
trouver une raison de d'espérer he
vraiment je le pense j'ai peut-être tort
mais je veux
dire
l'histoire vous incite quand même va
être assez positif parce que on trouve
les solutions alors souvent il y a du
sang sur les murs entre tempemps ça
c'est sûr c'est sûr mais on finit par
régler les problèmes je reviens à mes
bouquins soleil vert c'est pas mal non
Soleil Vert vous l'avez lu j'ai vu un
film qui s'appelait soleil vert avec
charleton et Stone un film des années 70
on transforma les viux en croquettes
exactement il y avait les soleils verts
précisément fait avec les cadavres et
puis les soleils jaunes c'était
terrifiant non le le le le il y a un
livre euh paru récemment alors il est en
anglais il s'appelle The Force turning
le 4e tournant et qui justement m'a
beaucoup inspiré dans cette théorie des
cycles il est écrit par un homme qui
s'appelle Neil
h o W euh il avait écrit le précédent
que j'avais lu il y a une dizaine
d'années avec un monsieur straos qui est
mort depuis et c'est ça ceussi la
démographie euh la politique la finance
c'est éblouissant éblouissant et ces
typeslà publient leur premier livrees en
euh et en 97 ils vous disent voilà vers
2005 2007 il y aura une grave crise
financière ENF c'est lumineux dans dans
dans les dans les prévisions dans
l'anticipation ça c'est un livre
important après les livres importants
pour moi ne sont pas des livres
économiques il y a le meilleur livre
économique je pense écrit euh par
Bernard Maris c'est gilles Dostaler ça
s'appelle paix à son âme euh capitalisme
et pulsion de mort c'est sur vous savez
que Freud et Kens se sont non pas connus
mais écrit curieusement a qui était au
milieu ou pas non pardon a qui était au
milieu non je pense pas mais et et donc
Dostaler est le spécialiste de Kees
maris il était encyclopédique donc mais
il s'intéressait beaucoup à la
psychanalyse et c'est le rapport à
l'argent chez les deux personnag
et et finalement chez nous tous quoi
c'est c'est c'est profond c'est puissant
euh c'est vraiment un livre qui qui qui
vous élève quoi qui vous élève
l'esprit le trisème
euh je pense un livre qui m'a beaucoup
intéressé récemment de Charles Goodheart
je n'ai plus son titre mais c'est un
livre de démographie qui explique que
finalement euh la période de
désinflation des 40 dernières années
était liée à l'augmentation du nombre de
personnes dans la population mondiale
population active mondiale que ça a créé
une pression à la baisse sur les salaire
et donc ça a permis de baisser les prix
mais dit-il comme on ça s'inverse en ce
moment toutes les populations actives
sont en train de se rétrécir on entre
probablement et il a publié son bouquin
il y a 2 ou 3 ans dans une période
inflationniste et dans une période où le
travail va retrouver le rapport de force
face au capital the great demmographic
reversal voilà je me souviens du titre
si on devait commencer un bouquin de
François l'anglais parmi la dizaine de
bouquins qu'il a pu écrire on
commencerait par lequel oh il faut faut
lire soit celui qui vient de sortir qui
s'appelle combien de temps ça va durer
qui est une un un recueil réaménagé de
chronique donc qui est pour un public
qui est pas économiste qui qui a qui a
envie de petits texte court c'est une
mosaïque de petit texte court qui
j'espère
dessine enfin forme un dessin cohérent
celui d'avant est sur le même thème mais
il est plus construit ça s'appelle rien
ne va trois petits points
mais celui sur la géopolitique oui il y
a une grande partie géopolitique alors
il y a aussi de il y en a un qui a été
écrit oui alors qui bien sûr qui
s'appelait La guerre des empires c'était
en en
2000 c'est un petit peu plus 2009 vous
avez raison c'était pour dire on vous
dit que la Chine et les États-Unis
s'entendent bien ça va pas durer et il y
aura une guerre entre les deux un
conseil pour les jeunes générations une
bouteille à la mer quelque chose
d'impérissable qui restera sur les
réseaux avant la prochaine la et autes
pour mes frèes les épaules
là croyez en vous c'est c'est c'est
c'est le le monde le le enfin vous êtes
aux portes du pouvoir et faites-en bon
usage François Langlais merci merci à
[Musique]
vous